Du denkst wahrscheinlich, dass...
So, ich glaube jetzt ist...
Ja, ja, ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Hast du auf dem Host
WSL 2 installiert?
Und wenn ja, wie hast du das konfiguriert,
dass in deinem Vmware nested
Virtualization klappt? Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich glaube,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, ich hatte
die gleichen Probleme wie du.
Wenn man... Also nicht nur
WSL 2, generell
wenn man die Windows
11 Virtualisierungs
Zeug
aktiviert...
Auf dem zweiten Bildschirm geht einfach nicht mehr.
Was ist jetzt? Wenn man die Windows 11
Virtualisierungskacke
aktiviert, dann hat
Vmware Probleme.
In Vmware musste man dann irgendeine
Option setzen, glaube ich, dass es wieder
funktioniert. Aber das kann durchaus
sein, dass nested Virtualisierung bei mir
dann auch nicht geklappt hat.
Ich habe dieses ganze Windows 11
Virtualisierungs Zeug habe ich aus.
Grüß, danke für den Sub.
Das habe ich alles
aus.
Ich meine, ich brauche auch kein
WSL. Ich habe halt ein richtig
echtes Linux, was mir viel, viel
lieber ist als ein WSL.
Ich muss jetzt mal gerade checken.
Ich habe euch nämlich was aufgenommen
unterwegs. Weiß nicht, ob das
was geworden ist.
Da muss ich euch aber mal kurz
ausblenden.
RIP Docker Desktop, warum?
Ach so, Docker Desktop unter Windows,
oder wie?
Oder was willst du machen?
Docker Desktop
unter Windows? Das ist aber echt
Hardcore Pains Champ schon, ne?
Ich weiß, dass ihr gerade nichts seht,
übrigens.
Ich will mal ein Video
von meinem iPhone rüberziehen. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was ich da alles
leake, was ich
nicht leaken möchte.
Deswegen habe ich euch gleich mal ausgeblendet.
Und ich bin mir auch nicht sicher,
ob das Aufnehmen überhaupt
geschieht.
Ob das das richtige Video
ist.
VLC starten.
Ja,
das ist das richtige Video.
Alles klar.
Moment, ich mache euch wieder an und ich mache das
iPhone erstmal ab.
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
So.
Jetzt mache ich euch wieder an.
Moment.
Da. So.
Das Problem mit WSL 2 ist immer,
mir fallen immer keine großen Gründe
immer so
retrospektivisch ein.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich
längere Zeit WSL 2 probiere,
geht es mir auf den Sack und ich bin froh, dass ich ein
vollwertiges Linux habe.
Ich hatte sogar irgendwo mal eine Liste angefangen,
warum, was an
WSL 2 nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und
ich weiß aber nicht mehr,
wo.
Also ich war oft,
als ich das ausprobiert habe, froh oder schnell.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung mehr, was so die großen
Probleme mit WSL 2 waren.
Habe ich, wo habe ich denn?
Ich habe irgendwo eine Liste erstellt.
Aber ich glaube nicht hier.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wo ich das habe.
Chat, fällt euch irgendwas
ein, was mit WSL 2
nicht gescheit funktioniert?
Ich finde das nicht mehr.
Ich gucke gerade auf meinem zweiten
in meinem Notes,
in meinen Notes,
dem zweiten Rechner.
Aber ich finde, ich habe mir extra eine Liste
gemacht, was mir an WSL
nicht gefallen hat.
Vielleicht müssen wir es im Stream ausprobieren, dass wir
live drauf kommen, was kacke ist.
Es gibt einige Sachen, die mir unglaublich auf den Sack
gegangen sind. Deswegen habe ich das nie weiterverwendet.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, du kannst
ja in WSL beispielsweise auch nicht
gescheit i3 laufen lassen und sowas.
Du kannst ja kein gescheites Desktop Environment
also sagen wir mal so, du kannst das
bestimmt mit sehr viel
Getrickse laufen lassen, aber
das ist ja nicht so.
Das ist ja nicht so.
Das funktioniert nicht gescheit.
Dann mit dem, selbst mit
dem Microsoft X Server, dass das oder
das ist ja gar kein X Server. Ich glaube
das WSL, wie heißt
das? WSLG oder so? Ist das nicht sogar
irgendein Wayland Gedöns?
Ja, aber allein schon, weil ich
i3 verwenden will unter Linux.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube so Sachen wie SSHFS
gingen auch nicht richtig.
Wobei, nee, das war ein WSL1 Problem, glaube ich.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Aber
trust me, Bro.
Wie man da so schön sagt
heutzutage. Das hat schon seinen Grund, warum ich WSL
nicht verwende. Ist mir oft
zu sehr auf den Sack gegangen. Ohne
dass ich dir jetzt sagen kann, was das genau
die Probleme waren im Einzelnen.
Ja gut, aber
aber das ist auch trotzdem
VMs. Wenn du WSL
hast, WSL ist doch auch ne VM.
Also du kommst für Docker an der VM
eh nicht vorbei. Ok, Windows
Container vielleicht. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es da so viele VMS gibt.
Weil ich, wie gesagt, absolut keine Ahnung habe, wie Windows Container
funktionieren. Wahrscheinlich ist es unter der
Haube dann Windows VM für jeden Container.
Was ist deine Meinung
zum Bahnstreik? Findest du die Forderung
der GDL berechtigt?
Ich, ok. Ja.
Ja, also keine, also
ob die berechtigt ist oder nicht
im Bahnkontext, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich finde die Forderung, das ist
tatsächlich eine sehr vielschichtige Frage.
Ja, also ich finde die Forderung
der GDL gut.
Weil, nee,
nicht weil ich irgendwie komplett selbstlos bin und
will, dass die unbedingt hier das alles
bekommen. Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das scheißegal.
Hauptsache die Bahn funktioniert.
Das, was mir persönlich
gefällt ist an der Forderung von der
GDL, dass die
35 Stunden Woche fordern.
Und das, ich bin da recht egoistisch
und ich finde es
an jeder Ecke gut, wo
weniger als klassische 40 Stunden,
38 Stunden Woche gefordert wird, weil
umso normaler
das wird, umso normaler
das wird, umso größer
sind die Chancen, dass das mal
ja, ob das jemals
gesetzlich kommt, wage ich zu bezweifeln,
aber umso größer sind die Chancen, dass das
immer normaler wird. Und wisst ihr,
was das heißt, wenn das immer normaler wird,
4 Tage Woche zu arbeiten?
Ratet mal, was könnte das
heißen für jemand, der
schon 4 Tage arbeitet in der Woche?
Was könnte das bedeuten?
Es gibt 2 Varianten.
Entweder 3 Tage Woche Incoming,
oder volles Gehalt
bei weiter 4 Tage.
Also insofern,
also insofern, ich bin da gar nicht so selbstlos,
da ich selbst seit
seit 10 Jahren
glaub sogar schon, 4 Tage Woche
arbeite, bin ich
sofort dafür, alle 4 Tage
Woche zu geben, was nämlich dann bedeuten würde,
ich krieg 100% Geld.
Also das finde ich, den
Part der Forderung finde ich tatsächlich gut.
Umso normaler wird das, wird umso besser.
Ich hab letztens auch einen Artikel gelesen,
das glaub ich die Commerzbank oder irgendjemand
das auch machen möchte,
da ist es dann irgendwie so,
dass man
4 Tage
Woche bekommt, bei vollem
Gehalt, allerdings
nicht komplett einen Tag die
Arbeitszeit reduziert wird, wenn ich das richtig
im Hinterkopf hab. Also da wird dann quasi
reduziert von, sagen wir mal,
40 Stunden auf
36 Stunden oder so.
Und
du darfst sie dann aber halt
an 4 Tagen anstatt an 5 arbeiten, das heißt
du musst jeden Tag eine Stunde länger da bleiben und sowas in der Richtung.
Also
die decken sich alle Modelle aus gerade
und umso normaler das wird, umso
besser ist das.
Ja, also ich find das, ich find das gut.
So, und die andere Frage ist,
ob ich
Alter, ich bin ja gerade gerannt
wieder meine
10,5 Kilometer, mir läuft immer noch die Nase.
Sekunde, warte mal.
Also,
das ist ja eine sehr vielschichtige
Frage, deswegen würde ich gerne sagen,
ähm,
die, also,
gucken wir mal auf Twitter.
Da gibt's ja die Leute, die immer so was
dann ganz
so,
so moralisch schreiben,
meinen vollsten Support an die
GDL, jeder der das
nicht für gut heißt, ist ein Kack-Spaß,
so nach dem Motto und
ja, immer, weil, alles Gute,
Leute und so, also ich finde,
das ist ne, das kann ich nicht
teilen, und da sieht man mal
wie widersprüchlich
man eigentlich Sachen finden kann, also
prinzipiell muss ich sagen,
wenn mich jemand fragen
würde, sollte man verbieten,
dass die Bahn, oder generell, sollte man
das den Leuten verbieten, dass sie streiken,
dann würde ich sagen, nein, sollte man nicht.
Das ist denen ihr Recht, das dürfen sie.
Da wäre ich auch, da würde ich tatsächlich
auch, wenn man da aus irgendwelchen Gründen angenommen würde,
dürfte abstimmen, so, dürfte man das verbieten.
Würde ich dagegen stimmen,
das würde ich bei allen dagegen stimmen,
dass das verboten werden sollte, trotzdem,
umgedrehter Fall,
ist mir das eigentlich scheißegal, und ich bin
abgefuckt, dass das scheiß nicht funktioniert.
Also ich habe keine Solidarität,
wie soll man das sagen, mit den Streikenden,
ich bin aber für das Recht,
dass sie streiken dürfen, versteht mal, was ich meine,
das ist irgendwie sehr
widersprüchlich, aber so ist es, ja.
Ich meine nur, weil
ich das prinzipiell richtig finde, dass sie streiken dürfen,
und streiken heißt es nicht,
dass ich es geil finden muss,
dass sie streiken.
Und,
dass die, mir ist es auch egal,
wer da jetzt was für kann, oder nicht,
letztendlich
ist es verkackt,
wie vieles bei der Bahn,
historische Entscheidungen,
Managemententscheidungen,
auf Regierungsebene Entscheidungen,
und generell ist die Bahn einfach mal komplett am Arsch,
der Weselski hat ja letztens auch
irgendwie so den
den
Telephone-Drop hingelegt,
indem er irgendwie gesagt hat,
in irgendeinem Interview,
dass sich jetzt ausgerechnet die CSU
beschwert, das war irgendwas in Bayern, glaube ich,
dass sich jetzt ausgerechnet die CSU beschwert,
ist ja schon ein kompletter Witz,
die sind ja dafür verantwortlich, dass die Bahn so ein
Scheißladen ist, das hat er nicht wortwörtlich gesagt,
aber sinngemäß.
Der hat ja schon ein paar Dinge rausgehauen.
Die Bahn ist gefühlt immer streik,
in letzter Zeit sehr oft.
Es gab letztens eine Statistik, habe ich gesehen,
Pünktlichkeiten
der
öffentlichen, tja,
Bahninfrastruktur
in den jeweiligen Ländern,
die Schweiz war ganz weit oben,
Italien kam noch vor uns,
und wir waren auf dem vorletzten Platz,
nach uns kam nur noch
Slowenien, und ich glaube
wir hatten 65%
oder so, oder
70%
oder irgendwie sowas der
Züge, das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zeigen,
die sind so unglaublich bodenlos
Scheiße, dieser Drecksladen,
ich könnte mich den ganzen Tag
nur über die, wisst ihr ja, muss ich jetzt nicht
muss ich jetzt nicht anfangen,
danach darf ich nicht anfangen,
ja,
aber wisst ihr,
jetzt mal, jetzt mal,
jetzt mal Spaß beiseite,
überlegt euch mal,
vor drei Wochen
oder so, und
und das, und das,
das ist richtig,
Take Viagra hat das richtig,
die Bahn dürfen
ihre eigene Statistik erstellen,
die dürfen die Regel für die eigenen
Statistiken festlegen,
die dürfen die Ziele, die erreicht werden,
quasi mehr oder weniger selbst
festlegen, und trotzdem
werden die verfehlt, das musst du erst mal
schaffen, also, da könnt ihr Gift drauf
nehmen, wenn ich meine eigene Statistik
erstellen dürfte, und mir die eigenen Regeln
dafür ausdecken dürfte,
und dann auch noch überlegen dürfte,
quasi, wann was gilt und was nicht,
dann würde ich aber wenigstens im Ziel
bleiben, aber nein und nicht mal das kriegen sie
auf die Reihe, könnt ihr sicher sein,
ja, das funktioniert nicht,
aber,
jetzt Spaß beiseite, was ich
eigentlich sagen wollte ist, müsst ihr euch überlegen,
vor drei Wochen war der erste
Bahnstreik dieses Jahr,
Anfang Januar,
dann war
Unwetter,
und,
Bauern in Frankfurt,
dann war Glatteis,
und Schnee, und Dingsbums,
Chaos, und jetzt ist wieder
Bahnstreik, ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
du konntest quasi,
drei Wochen lang jetzt,
wir sind nicht in irgendeinem Loch in Afrika
oder so, ja, wir sind in Hessen,
in Deutschland, in Frankfurt,
nicht irgendwo in der dritten Welt,
du konntest quasi drei
Wochen nicht
mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln
gescheit fahren, drei Wochen,
wie gesagt,
wir sind nicht in einem dritten Weltland, irgendwo
im Busch, in irgendeinem Loch in Afrika, nein,
und da
funktioniert das besser, da wärst du in drei Wochen angekommen,
okay, ich mein, du wärst vielleicht unterwegs,
erschossen, erstochen, sonst,
wobei, du musst durch
Offenbach durchfahren,
ich nehm das zurück, vielleicht ist das auch
kein Unterschied, ja,
gut, ich glaube,
es ist zumindest hier immer noch ein bisschen sicherer,
die Strecke zu fahren, ja,
das ist wirklich,
das ist wirklich echt
affig, wenn man sich das überlegt,
drei Wochen lang, dass du es komplett
vergessen konntest,
ja, ja, ich nehm das zu, wie gesagt,
muss man sagen, so ungefährlich
ist es ja hier auch nicht, es gab hier die letzte
Zeit wieder einige
Meldungen über Leute mit
Messer am Bahnhof, Messer
im Zug, mit der Axt,
gab's auch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit,
mit der Axt, wo jemand durch
den Zug gelaufen ist und versucht hat,
Leute anzu-Axten,
der wurde dann erschossen, hat es die Leute
wieder aufgeregt, warum wurde der denn erschossen?
Ah ja, der ist mit der Axt durch den Zug gerannt
und wollte auf Leute einschlagen.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
ich weiß ja nicht, wie ihr das seht,
da gibt's immer so große Diskussionen,
also, ich bin wirklich nicht dafür,
dass das so läuft, wie
Kekona, Kekona Land,
hell yeah, dass alles
abgeknallt wird, was beteiligt auf
den Bäumen ist, ja,
das muss ja nicht sein, oder, äh,
wenn du die falsche Hautfarbe hast, dass
dann die Polizei auf dich rumspringt, oder was,
da bin ich ja wirklich nicht dafür,
aber wir machen teilweise das,
die Amis haben andere Probleme,
wir haben teilweise echt, ist das hier
echt übertrieben, bei
jeder,
wie soll man sagen,
fast schon
Pflichterfüllung der Polizei,
wird ultra rumgejammert, ich hab
letztens ein Video gesehen, das war
so ein typisches Video von der Kategorie,
was ich mir nicht hätte angucken sollen, weil eigentlich,
kann man sich sowas nicht angucken, aber, war auf Twitter,
steht, stehen
drei oder vier Polizisten auf der
Straße, und vor ihnen steht ein halbnackiger Typ
mit einem Messer in der Hand,
und die schreien ihn halt an,
er soll nicht näher kommen, er soll das Messer
weglegen, sie gehen sogar noch einen Schritt
zurück, er soll das Messer weglegen,
und dann läuft er halt auf die zu mit dem Messer
nach vorne, und dann erschießen sie ihn,
da denk ich mir so, what the fuck,
alter, was,
ich, warum
regt man sich da drüber auf,
ich mein,
wer auf der Straße steht mit dem Messer,
die Leute bedroht,
mit dem gezwickten Messer Richtung
Polizei läuft, auch noch,
da musst du doch mit rechnen,
dass du die Sache nicht überlebst,
ich, ich hab keine Ahnung, versteh das auch nicht,
wie sie sich drüber aufgeregt haben, dass sie den Kerl,
der im Zug rumgelaufen ist, mit der Axt
erschossen haben, ja man, wenn
einer in den Zug einsteigt,
mit dem Hintergedanken, jetzt mit der Axt auf ein paar Leute
einzuschlagen, dann muss der halt damit rechnen,
dass er den Scheiß nicht überlebt, es ist ja nicht, als hätte
jemand dazu gezwungen, mit der Axt
in den Zug einzusteigen und auf Leute einzuschlagen,
da musst du damit rechnen,
das versteh ich teilweise echt nicht,
ich persönlich, muss ehrlich sagen,
ich hab auch nicht nur gute
Erfahrungen mit der Polizei gemacht, aber
insgesamt
finde ich eigentlich die Arbeit der Polizei
ziemlich gut, ja und wir können
froh sein, dass wir gut ausgebildete Polizisten
haben und nicht Kona-Style,
wenn du dir das da teilweise anguckst, das ist ja echt
nicht mehr normal.
Was ist an Offenbach so besonders?
Haftbefehl.
Eigentlich ist
an Offenbach gar nichts mehr so großartig
besonders, Offenbach ist halt gerade
was Hauptbahnhof und Umgebung angeht
ziemlich runtergekommen, ha, gut
Frankfurt auch, ja,
ist in Frankfurt jetzt nicht viel anders,
ist halt, also historisch
war Offenbach halt immer so ein bisschen
Brennpunkt, weil das einen extrem hohen
Ausländeranteil hat
und da ging es gerade
im Bahnhofsviertel früher immer
zur Sache und auch was Kriminalitätsraten
angeht und sowas, war Offenbach halt früher
berühmt,
berüchtigt,
aber mittlerweile würde ich sagen,
ist Offenbach auch nicht mehr so wild,
zumal Offenbach ja auch nicht nur Hauptbahnhof ist,
genauso wenig wie Frankfurt
ist,
Frankfurt ist ja auch nicht nur Bahnhofsviertel,
wenn man Reddit guckt, Reddit,
Reddit Frankfurt,
da wird,
da wird gefühlt jeden Tag fünfmal
gefragt, ist es
sicher am Hauptbahnhof rumzulaufen
und so
und ich weiß auch nicht, das ist mittlerweile
schon so ein Reddit Frankfurt Meme,
ist es sicher am Hauptbahnhof,
ja, es ist
sicher am Hauptbahnhof, wir sind
hier nicht irgendwie in den Slums in Brasilien
oder so, du kannst am Hauptbahnhof
in Frankfurt ohne Probleme
rein und raus laufen,
ohne dass du erschossen, erstochen,
abgefackelt wirst,
sag mal so, dich kotzt vielleicht
irgendein Penner an oder so, das kann schon mal
passieren, oder vor dich,
oder, ja, oder es fällt
einer hin vor dir, oder es
schreit dich einer von das, also es ist schon,
schon weird champ am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof,
aber es ist nicht,
soll man sagen, nicht akut gefährlich
da für Leib und Leben,
aber man sieht halt Sachen,
die man nicht sehen will, ja,
du siehst zum Beispiel, dass,
da gibt's, weiß nicht,
hab ich schon letztens irgendwas,
aber letztens ist gut, das ist bestimmt auch schon ein Jahr her,
ein Bild gepostet,
auf Twitter, Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof,
da lag einer in irgendeinem
Schaufenster, also es war kein Schaufenster
mehr drin, lag irgendein Typ im Schaufenster
und hat gepennt, halb,
halb drinnen, halb draußen im Schaufenster,
mit nackigem Hintern, halt
aus dem Schaufenster raus, lag da
und schla, äh, schlief,
es ist halt, es ist halt Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof,
ja,
du hast dann auch Leute neben dir,
die auf einmal mit nackigen Füßen
in der Bahn hocken und sowas, also,
also die Assi-Quote Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
ist schon recht hoch, aber es ist nicht
gefährlich in diesem Sinn,
du wurdest gebannt auf dem Discord, das weiß ich nicht,
warum du auf dem Discord
gebannt wurdest, kann vielleicht
einer der Modkis was zu sagen,
aber ich hab's bis jetzt noch nie erlebt, dass jemand
komplett grundlos gebannt wurde, das heißt,
entweder hast du
Eigenwerbung in übertriebenem Maß betrieben,
fragwürdige Sachen gepostet,
auf wiederholte Aufforderung
von Modkis
weiterhin komische Sachen gepostet,
illegale Sachen gepostet,
oder was auch immer getrieben,
ja, und für
den Fall der Fälle, dass sich
wirklich jemand geirrt hat, kann sich das ja einer
der Modkis nochmal angucken, aber die wissen das, falls
überhaupt jemand da ist.
Ich hab nur Fragen zum IT-Job geschrieben,
das klingt jetzt eigentlich nicht bannwürdig,
Mod, Modcheck,
ich glaub, der Rinax ist da,
also keine Ahnung,
ja, ja, so ein bisschen schon,
was, er wurde gebannt, weil das
Profil was lustige
Pronomen enthielt,
oje, sind bestimmt irgendwelche
Leute triggert, also ich hab
keine Ahnung, um was es da genau ging,
ich denk, wir müssen bei sowas
auch nicht pipslicher sein als der Papst,
aber wenn ihr es für richtig haltet,
ich hab da Vertrauen in meine Modkis,
sonst könnten wir den Discord gar nicht betreiben.
Ja, war ich, achso, ich wollte euch eigentlich
ein Video zeigen,
und zwar,
ich hab heut gemerkt,
dass es echt anstrengend ist zu rennen,
deswegen hab ich versucht, mal
aus Motivationsgründen
ein Video aufzunehmen,
also, ich weiß nicht,
ob man mich überhaupt versteht
da drinnen,
aber ich hab mir gedacht,
ich nehm einfach mal kurz ne Minute auf
bei meiner Runde, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert,
naja gut,
sagen wir mal so, dass die Aufnahme funktioniert,
hab ich mir gedacht, ich weiß dann nicht,
ob man mich versteht,
natürlich wie der letzte Kacknub hochkant gefilmt,
ne, so richtig TikTok Generation,
zu der ich ja natürlich nicht gehöre,
ich bin 1984 geboren,
ich hab übrigens 184 Zuschauer, passt irgendwie,
mal gucken, ob man mich versteht,
aber man sieht, schönes Wetter,
schönes Wetter,
ja, man versteht was, oder?
Ja, man versteht was,
man hört, dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen
aus der Puste bin,
so minimal, ja,
aber hallo Leute, hier ist der Max,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das gescheit funktioniert,
aber echt schönes Wetter, oder?
Aber ich dachte mir so aus
Motivationsgründen,
ne, nehm ich mal kurz
bisschen von meiner Sonntagsrunde auf,
aktuell ist gerade,
guck mal,
what the, Max, erkennt man da irgendwas?
Erkennt man auf,
erkennt man, Sekunde,
erkennt man hier irgendwas?
Aktuell ist gerade,
guck mal,
oh, ich hab mich bestimmt
gespiegelt in der Uhr, MonkaS,
ja doch, man erkennt was,
tatsächlich, tatsächlich,
Spiegelung in der Uhr,
bestimmt gewesen, also da
erkennt man's,
halbes Face Reveal, ja,
halbes Face Reveal,
mit dem T-Shirt, ne, ich hab kein T-Shirt angehabt,
liegt,
Teile der Hand
und Arm liegt,
also was sieht man denn da drauf?
Haare am Arm liegt,
ja, also was,
was sieht man da drauf? Also das da oben ist die
errechnete Wattangabe,
die ist sehr mit Vorsicht
zu genießen, ja, sehr mit Vorsicht
zu genießen, so aktuell
haben wir
3,1, also an der Stelle hatte ich
3,13 Kilometer,
ich bin 20 Minuten ungefähr
gelaufen, 6 Minuten
25 pro Kilometer aktueller
Pace,
was ist das?
Achso, Time of Day, oder sowas,
9 Uhr 11,
und 161er Puls,
wo die Uhr der Meinung ist, dass es
obere,
vorletzte, obere Hälfte
der vorletzten, ja,
Anstrengungszone
von mir, sagt meine Uhr, ja,
wenn die das sagt, dann,
dann wird's so sein,
was ist das für eine Uhr? Das ist
eine Garmin
Forerunner 200,
S,
ich mein, die ist nicht in pink, ich hab
so ein ganz normales graues
graues Armband,
aber die ist ganz nice,
die ist nicht so teuer
wie manche andere Uhren, und
also was ich an der Uhr mag, jetzt gucken wir mal gerade,
was das Ding bei Amazon kostet, die sind da oftmals schlecht
lieferbar, oh nein, schon wieder Postleitzahl
liegt,
ja, 264 Euro,
ich find, das geht eigentlich voll klar,
was ich an der, was ich an der Uhr
ziemlich gut finde, ist die Akkulaufzeit,
weil, wenn man das mal vergleicht
mit einer, sagen wir, Apple, Apple
Watch, dann hält
die halt zehnmal so lang,
die kannst du ne Woche rumliegen lassen, oder
beziehungsweise benutzen und ne Woche nicht aufladen,
so ne Apple Watch
ist nach einem Tag, oder je nachdem
wie oft, wie viel man davon benutzt, auch schneller,
leer, natürlich hat die
bei weitem kein so großes und so hochauflösendes
und so detailreiches Display,
sie hat ein,
so ein Pulsmesser hat's da drinne,
und
insgesamt
ist es vielleicht jetzt nicht die absolute High-End
Uhr, aber die
Akkulaufzeit ist
nice, Preis-Leistung finde ich nice,
und was ich bei Garmin persönlich gut
finde, ist das große
Ökosystem aus
Plugins und Datenfeldern
und sowas, wir haben ja schon mal im Stream ein eigenes
Datenfeld für meinen Fahrradcomputer
programmiert, und dass man sie
ultra nice customizen kann, ja,
man hat auch die wichtigsten
Daten schon mit drinne, man kann auch diesen
automatischen Trainingsplan-Generator
benutzen, wenn man das mag, das verwende ich aber nicht,
ansonsten ist die echt
nice, kann ich gar nicht sagen,
fühlt sich gut an, man drückt
auch nicht aus versehen die Knöpfe, die Bedienung
ist, nachdem man sich dran gewöhnt hat,
sehr eingängig, also ich find
die Uhr gut,
ich würd die mir auch wiederholen,
was auch, was ich persönlich auch sehr sehr
praktisch finde, ist
dass wenn man Strecken läuft,
die man nicht kennt, da kann man
beispielsweise über Komoot oder
irgendwo irgendwas, wo du GPS-Daten, also
nicht GPS, wie heißt der, GPX,
GPX, also wo du so
Tracking, wo du so Wege
quasi exportieren kannst,
kannst du dir kopieren auf die Uhr
oder importieren, die meisten Wande-Apps
haben ja auch schon eine Connect-Funktion
zu Garmin, und dann
kannst du quasi die Navigation auf der
Uhr machen, das ist die,
die hat keine Kartenfunktion, also
dafür ist das Display nicht gut genug, du kannst
keine Karten rendern im Hintergrund, aber
du kannst dir so eine rote Linie anzeigen
lassen, und das reicht ja auch, weil du siehst
den Pfeil, in welche Richtung du guckst,
und du siehst die rote Linie
und die Auflösung von der roten Linie,
ob du dich auf deinem richtigen Pfad befindest.
Also, wenn ich irgendwo wandern
gehe und den Weg nicht kenne,
dann navigier
ich mittlerweile eigentlich zu 90%
mit der Uhr und hol das
Handy bloß an Stellen raus, wo es nicht ganz
eindeutig ist.
Und das ist viel nicer, als wenn man
beispielsweise irgendwie durch, bisschen durchs Gelände
läuft, und dann irgendwie noch
zusätzlich zu vielleicht links und rechts
einem Stock
noch irgendwie das Handy rausholen muss,
um da drauf zu gucken, und dann noch aufs Maul fällt,
weil man nicht richtig gucken kann aufs Handy.
Also die Navigationsfunktion
sieht zwar super primitiv aus,
ist aber enorm praktisch.
Und nachdem man auch alle Datenfelder
so customizen kann, ist das
sehr nice.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ja,
bei meinem Video. Wie gesagt, habe ich für euch
heute Morgen aufgenommen, weil so aus Motivationsgründen
ich habe ein bisschen,
ich habe ein bisschen nachgelassen um Weihnachten.
Wir gucken uns aber das Video erstmal fertig an.
Bisschen von meiner Sonntagsrunde auf.
Aktuell ist gerade,
guck mal,
naja, man hat's
gesehen, 625
pro Kilometer,
162 Puls.
Beim Reden geht das jetzt auch ein bisschen hoch.
Und ich dachte mir so aus Motivationsgründen.
Das ist aber echt schönes Wetter.
Außer mit schönem Wetter. Ja.
Nimm ich mal kurz auf.
Neue Bestzeiten und so gibt's nicht.
Ich bin ein bisschen
faul gewesen über Weihnachten, aber...
Ja, das stimmt. Bin ich nicht so viel
gerannt über Weihnachten.
Es ging aber auch teilweise nicht, ne?
Megascheiß Wetter, Glatteis
und alles jetzt die letzten Tage.
Guck mal, wie süß das ist.
Irgendwann demnächst probier ich mal
11 Kilometer oder 10 Kilometer
irgendwas dazwischen.
Und dann unter 6 Kilometern pro Kilometer.
Die Runde heute ist auch
ungefähr 11 Kilometer.
Also ich hab jetzt
hab ich jetzt
3, ne
3,26, also ein Drittel
oder so ungefähr.
Wenn man da großzügig ist.
Macht's gut, ich komm weiter.
Bis dann, CU.
Hauptsache CU am Ende.
Hab ich mir gedacht,
ich nehm das mal auf. Vielleicht motiviert's
mich ja selbst.
Ja, heute
waren's knapp 10
Kilometer.
Also es war nicht die
noch größere Runde.
Sondern nur die
10 Kilometer Runde. Ich hab ja,
das ist eigentlich ganz nice,
ich hab ja die Möglichkeit bei mir
quasi
mit dem gleichen Anfang der Runde
kann ich entweder
5 Kilometer laufen,
6,2 Kilometer laufen,
8, 10 oder
11,5 laufen.
Das ist alles immer quasi so die gleiche Runde.
Aber unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche Abzweigungen.
Das heißt, je nachdem wie's mir grade ist,
kann ich
das variieren.
Und heute war's
mir so nach der zweitgrößten Runde.
Aber nicht die ganz große, da hatt ich keinen Bock drauf.
Und ja, war ich schon.
Aber insgesamt, um
das jetzt abzuschließen, war's
heut echt nicht gut.
Schade heute.
Passt mal auf.
Okay.
Egal, das hat keinen Bock
hochkant zu gehen.
Ich bin heute gelaufen, ziemlich genau.
Also knapp 10 Kilometer.
Durchschnittliche Herzfrequenz 162.
Ja gut, hat man da auch gesehen.
So viel hatte ich da ja auch ungefähr.
6 Minuten 33 sogar nur
pro Kilometer.
Kalorien geburnt.
Eine Stunde fünf.
Und von den Stats her,
ist das eigentlich relativ
langweilig.
Was ich doof finde,
ist, also der sagt,
Trainingseffekt
sind 5,0. Mehr geht nicht.
Mehr Trainingseffekt
kann man nicht machen.
Laut Garmin ist das, also ich hab quasi den
maximalen Trainingseffekt.
Frag mich, was Garmin anzeigen würde, wenn ich
12 Kilometer gerannt wäre.
Weil mehr als 5,0
geht nicht.
Allerdings ist meine
Performance Condition
schlecht.
Meine Performance Condition,
also
wo Garmin das errechnet, weiß ich
nicht genau. Wahrscheinlich irgendeine Mischung aus
Herzfrequenz,
Geschwindigkeit und
Schrittfrequenz
und
keine Ahnung, wie Garmin das überhaupt
errechnet. Zumindest ist die
nie im Plusbereich gewesen
heute. Die schwankte zwischen
0 und teilweise
minus
2 mit
ganz kurz mal bis
ganz ganz kurz mal minus 4.
Minus, also die schwankte
zwischen minus 2, äh
zwischen 0 und minus 3 und mal ganz
kurz, ganz 2 Minuten minus 4.
Heute, da war nicht so
nicht so gut.
Meine Performance Condition.
So.
Wie viele Gigabyte RAM
ein Browser braucht. Gar nicht so viel, wie man denkt
leider. Guck mal, ich hab hier
Tabs, ich hab hier Tabs und ich hab hier noch ein paar Tabs.
Und ich hab eigentlich
normalerweise, Sekunde, das müssen wir jetzt auch an der Stelle
gerade mal machen. Nicht, dass das jetzt
nicht, dass das unbenutzt
bleibt. Nicht, dass
das unbenutzt bleibt.
Der
RAM, der Iron
Champ ist am Start.
Du sitzt hier rum und Garmin meint Stress.
Ich glaube, die machen das anhand irgendwie der
Leitfähigkeit von der Haut oder so.
So, wir machen jetzt mal kurz Package
Update. Schadet
nicht. So, und jetzt können wir
gucken, wie viel RAM Usage ich hab.
Jetzt nehm ich die VM auf
und ich hab RAM Usage
Wie? Nur?
Ist ja nix.
18 Gigabyte.
Leute, ich hab 64 Gigabyte RAM.
Ach ja, ich hab übrigens meinen RAM
runtergetaktet wieder. Ich hab
ja OC, OC RAM.
Aber mein Rechner ist
jetzt die letzten paar Wochen
ab und an mal gepluscreent.
Und da hab
ich meinen RAM wieder auf normale Taktraten
zurückgetaktet.
Ja, guckt euch das mal an.
Ich hab ja, wofür brauch ich den ganzen
RAM eigentlich? 20 Gigabyte
von 67, Mann, das ist ja
kacke.
Komplett umsonst.
Ja, genau.
Ich hab XMP, XMP,
ja, das Zeug hab ich ausgeschaltet.
Auf den normalen Takt
gestellt.
Also ich mein, ich hab im Endeffekt
die Raten ausgewählt,
mit denen ich den RAM gekauft hab.
Aber
es ist immerhin noch OC RAM.
Ja, wer weiß, wie genau die das getestet haben.
Und ganz ehrlich, die Performance-Einbußen
so zwischen
dem Takt und dem normalen Takt
und dem XMP-Takt, die sind ja wirklich zu
vernachlässigen. Und wenn es wirklich daran
liegt, dass mein Rechner deswegen ab und zu mal gecrashed
ist, dann lass ich
lieber runtergetaktet. Ist ja nicht als wäre der
so großartig schlecht dadurch jetzt auf einmal.
Paul, dankeschön.
Hast du vier Riegel drinne?
Nee. Oder?
Ich weiß es gar nicht. Nee.
Nee, nee. Glaub ich nicht. Moment, Moment.
Können wir kurz gucken.
Geizhals. Moment.
Ich hab übrigens
gestern ein neues Video aufgenommen.
Das muss ich nachher freischalten hier. Geizhals, mein
PC. Ich habe
zwei Riegel.
Zweimal 32.
Hier haben wir dem Bauer ein bisschen Geld
überwiesen. Indirekt.
Ist das nicht die
Thermal-Grizzly, ist da nicht
der Bauer irgendwie noch daran beteiligt?
Der Auer.
Der 8-Auer.
Yep.
Ich bilde mir ein,
das hat was gebracht, dass dadurch
die CPU ein paar Grade
Grade? Grade?
Ja, wie
heißt das richtig? Dass dann die CPU
ein paar Grad, Grad,
kälter ist.
Schon mal überlegt ECC-RAM zu verwenden?
Nee, auf dem Desktop. Ja, überlegt, aber auf dem Desktop
nicht. Brauchst du auch Mainboard, was das
unterstützt?
Weiß ich nicht, wie es da mit dem Support aussieht.
Außerdem gibt es
ECC-RAM denn mit RGB?
Ich würde vermuten,
ECC-RAM und RGB tritt nicht so oft
zusammen auf.
Also wenn es RGB-ECC-RAM
gäbe, weil RGB-RAM
ist enorm wichtig.
Ich hab zwar, ich hab deswegen extra eine
Fenster in meinem Computer drinnen, dass ich
reingucken kann. Das dumme ist nur, dass
das Fenster zugestellt ist vom anderen Rechner.
Ich hab bestimmt irgendwas.
Du meinst bei der Bahn?
Naja, unmittelbar
für mich ist der Streik ein Problem.
Aber
vor den Hintergründen, habe ich ja gerade gesagt, gehe ich
mal ganz stark davon aus, dass es eine klassische
Bahn-Mischung ist, verkackt die letzten
15 Jahre über auf
Management-Ebene, auf Regierungsebene,
auf Gesamtablauf.
Das Ding ist einfach so ein Drecksladen,
dass man sich da nicht so
an die Hand holen kann.
Ich bin nicht mit T-Shirt gerannt.
Ich hab einfach die Arme hochgekrempelt.
Oh, danke für den Sub.
So.
Excellent.
Ich muss mal kurz ins Creator-Dashboard gucken,
ob ich nicht irgendwelche Leute übersehen hab.
Nope.
Okay.
Dann mal gucken, ob das... Oh, was muss ich machen?
Achja. Okay, bestätigen.
Ja, ich dachte, wir machen mal eine Runde Package-Updates.
Package-Updates ist nicht verkehrt.
Was sagen die
JetBrains-Dinger? Brauchen die auch ein Update?
Warum ist die Musik
auf einmal so laut?
Die Playlist kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden.
So, JetBrains-Gedöns.
Gibt's auch Updates.
Wisst ihr, was mir letztens aufgefallen ist?
Wir verwenden ja öfters Rider hier, um C-Sharp zu
developen.
Ist euch eigentlich klar, dass wir
.NET mit Java-Unterbau
entwickeln? Damit?
Weil das ist eine JetBrains-Idee,
die ist immer in Java. Das ganze Zeug,
das ganze JetBrains-Zeug ist in Java programmiert.
Das heißt, wir verwenden eine
in Java entwickelte IDE,
um .NET zu entwickeln.
Nicht, dass das schlimm wäre, ja.
Das funktioniert.
Bei Go oder bei Python genau das gleiche.
Das ist halt alles der gleiche Java-Kern.
Daran sieht man, dass
Java einfach überlegen ist, ja.
Java einfach
der klassische
Giga-Jetmove.
Wobei, Java wirst du ja
in der Shep angeguckt. Im englischsprachigen
Bereich sagen die eigentlich alle Java.
Oder auch Javascript.
Hast du dich eigentlich für die Twitch später
für AV1-Streaming angemeldet? Nö.
Ihr wisst, wie motiviert ich immer bin,
mich bei Sachen anzumelden, ne?
Lieber C-Sharp mit Java, als mit Microsoft-Produkten
entwickeln. So doof das
klingt, das ist tatsächlich so.
Das ist eigentlich
lustig, ne?
Wenn du dir überlegst, du benutzt eine Microsoft-Technologie,
ein Framework von Microsoft,
eine Runtime von Microsoft,
komplette Ökosysteme von Microsoft,
aber die IDE suckt.
Die nicht von Microsoft.
Wobei, wenn man ehrlich sagen muss,
so schlecht ist Visual Studio
auch nicht. Das Problem,
Leute, wisst ihr, was das Problem an
Visual Studio ist?
Wer kommt drauf?
Nicht Visual Studio Code, Visual Studio.
Was ist das Problem an Visual Studio?
Visual Studio selbst ist gar nicht so
schlecht.
Das Problem ist,
dass Visual Studio unter Windows läuft.
Und das ist ein Problem.
Weil Softwareentwicklung unter Windows, da hätte ich echt
keinen Bock drauf. Das ist das eigentliche
Problem. Da gibt es übrigens eine lustige
Story von der Arbeit. Während ich hier mal meine
VM reboote, erzähle ich euch das mal kurz.
Und zwar,
bei mir auf der Arbeit, ich arbeite in Frankfurt
bei einer Versicherung, da ist ja alles so
super krass secure, abgesichert.
So, und es ist halt so,
wir haben, nur mal so ganz grob,
dass ihr ungefähr eine Ahnung davon habt, wie das
aufgebaut ist. Es gibt ein
Kubernetes Cluster in der Google Cloud.
Und
das ist ein extra Cluster, den wir
aufgebaut haben, dass die Entwickler
dort quasi
auch außerhalb von
ihrer lokalen Kiste mal den Zusammenspiel
der gesamten Softwarekomponenten testen
können. Also da kannst du quasi wild
deployen, wie du willst.
Im Endeffekt. So.
Jetzt das Ding.
Die Entwickler bekommen
eine Entwickler-VM.
Die Entwickler-VM
ist irgendeine Kiste, auf die
du per Remote Desktop zugreifst.
Nicht irgendwie etwa
lokal oder so auf dem Notebook, wo
alles ist. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Die bekommen eine
Entwickler-VM.
So, und jetzt gibt es manche Entwickler,
die connecten sich nicht
von ihrem vom Arbeitgeber zur Verfügung
gestellten Notebook,
auf diese Entwickler-VM,
sondern benutzen
einen Remote-Zugang.
Heißt im Endeffekt, die gehen dann
per Remote auf
diese VM. Also es ist dann quasi schon mal
quasi ein Remote-Programm,
um auf eine, um sich dort
auf eine VM zu gehen. Also Remote
auf eine VM. Und
von dort, von ihrer Entwickler-VM
kommen sie aber nirgendswohin.
Dafür haben sie da ihre IDE und alles mögliche,
was sie so brauchen. Ja, die haben da auch
zum größten Teil Jetbrains Zeug, manch
manche. Ich versteh's ja ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum.
Manche Leute, ist ja hauptsächlich
auch Java, weil Business Enterprise,
manche Leute
benutzen Eclipse. Könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen, dass es wirklich Entwickler gibt,
die Eclipse verwenden?
Was ist das für ein cooles
ASCII-Quarium, ja. ASCII-Quarium
ist das. Es gibt manche
Leute, die verwenden 2024 gerne
noch Eclipse. Oh Leute, ich
muss das Update nochmal machen, fällt mir auf.
Keck, wait, ich bin Kack-Noob.
Ich muss Snapshots von gestern reverten.
Snapshots löschen.
Ich erzähl euch in der Zwischenzeit
weiter, während ich das mache, weil ich
da Mist installiert hab.
Da kann ich gleich nochmal Eclipse installieren und wir
können's mal aufmachen. Wartet mal, Sekunde.
Weil wollte ich Hollywood installieren für
die Videoaufnahme.
Eclipse.
Gibt's das? Gibt's das Ding? Eclipse.
Guck mal, das gibt's doch nicht
mehr. Das gibt's doch nicht mehr
in den offiziellen Paketquellen zu installieren,
oder? Seh ich das richtig?
Ja, versteh ich auch, so ein Schrott.
Will ja auch keiner. Kackel, Alter.
Keck, wait. Okay.
So, Snapshots. Jetzt machen wir
Pac-Man-Updates, dann rebooten wir nochmal.
Machen wir das gleiche, was wir eben auch gemacht haben.
Toolbox.
Hallo? Toolbox.
Ja, updaten.
Ja, also
wie gesagt, es gibt Leute, die verwenden allen Ernstes
noch freiwillig Eclipse. Ich versteh's nicht. Zumindest
um die Story, äh, äh,
Long Story Short.
Das heißt, die greifen schon mal per
auf ihre Entwickler-VM zu. Von dieser
Entwickler-VM, da haben sie zwar ihre ganzen IDEs
und sonst was, kommen sie aber
nirgendswohin, weil alles super krass
highly secure. Aber die wollen ja
ihre Anwendungen nicht nur lokal testen,
die wollen ihre Anwendungen ja auch
quasi bauen und dann im
Kubernetes-Cluster testen, um das Zusammenspiel
zwischen allen anderen gescheit mal
testen zu können. Okay.
Jetzt ist das Problem,
jetzt müssen sie von ihrer
Entwickler-VM
auf
irgendwie sich
in die Cloud connecten können,
damit sie das Ganze
dort
ausprobieren können. Das Deployment der
Software in den Kubernetes-Cluster,
das müssen die nicht selbst machen, das geht über
ich glaub irgendeine GitLab-Pipeline
ist das, aber
um dort was auszuprobieren und zu gucken, wie sich
das verhält und so, da müssen sie irgendwie an den
Kubernetes-Cluster dran. Jetzt passt mal auf, weil
alles so super secure ist, der Weg
ist so ultra
umgedreht und es ist auch kein offizieller
Weg in dem Sinn, das ist ein Weg, den
ich mir und
eins, zwei andere Entwickler ausgedacht
hab. Und zwar,
als erstes verbinden die sich
remote auf
ihre Entwickler-VM.
Auf der Entwickler-VM
installieren sie sich
das Google Cloud SDK,
weil dort
dann das
Google Cloud Command Line Tool drin ist,
was man braucht, um sich quasi zu
authentifizieren gegen die Google Cloud.
Das Ding ist jetzt, du kannst das
Google Cloud SDK nicht installieren.
Ratet mal, Chatge,
warum du das Google Cloud SDK
nicht installieren kannst. Also mit dem, du lädst dir
den offiziellen für Windows Google Cloud
SDK Installer runter.
Du kannst es nicht installieren, ratet mal warum.
Eventuell ist einer
Big Brain und kennt sich im Business Enterprise Umfeld
aus und kann erraten,
woran das liegt,
dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ich gebe euch so lange Zeit,
bis ich ein Paket update.
Läuft euch was zu überlegen.
Wer richtig liegt, gewinnt einen Sub.
Software Restriction Policies.
Nein, die sind Admin, muss man sagen.
Die Leute haben Admin.
Die haben Admin-Rechte auf ihren Entwickler-VMs.
Auf die Idee sind sie auch schon gekommen,
dass es sonst suckt.
Ironwall.
Nee.
Aber das geht ungefähr in die Richtung.
Active Directory. Nein.
Andere MAC-Adresse. Nein.
Ja, es ist schwer drauf zu kommen.
Aber vielleicht hat ja einer
noch eine zündende Idee.
Ich sag's euch gleich, wenn das Paket update durch ist.
Und wenn ich rebooted hab.
Andere MAC-Adresse ist auch nicht.
Active Directory. Nein, DNS ist auch nicht schuld.
Virenscanner oder kein Internet.
Nein, man hat Internetzugriff.
Virenscanner ist es auch nicht.
Fonts. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Man darf kein eigenes Interface an.
Nee, braucht man dafür nicht.
Habt Web-Application.
Custom Enterprise. Haben wir,
aber dafür braucht man das nicht.
Ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch.
Ausgehender Traffic wird blockiert.
Nee. Ja. Ja und nein.
Ich sag's. SSL-Zeit. Ja.
Splixer. Du bist fast.
Ja. Leute.
Alter, der Chat ist so massive high IQ.
Chat, ich bin stolz auf euch.
Das ist zwar nicht genau das,
aber das ist schon nah genug dran.
Okay, ihr kriegt...
Der Splixer hat schon einen Sub, dem kann ich jetzt keinen geben.
Aber
dem Dungeon, dem kann ich einen Sub giften.
Jetzt.
Siehste mal, das ist die erste high IQ,
erste Message und dann gleich
Big Brain Message.
Ja, ja, ich agree, um mir
selbst 3,99€ zu überweisen.
Massive. Richtig.
SSL-Inspection.
Und zwar,
die kommen ins Internet von dort, allerdings nur
über so einen Man in the Middle
Geschichte. Ja, Proxy.
Ja, das war ja nicht spezifisch genug.
Das nur über so
eine Man in the Middle
SSL-Inspection
Geschichte. Und das Ding ist
jetzt, dass
der Google Cloud SDK
Installer, das basiert auf
Python, das ganze Google Cloud SDK,
der Installer auch, der verwendet nicht
den systemeigenen Trust Store
für Zertifikate. Das heißt,
der Installer trustet nicht
dem Zertifikat des
SSL Man in the Middle Dings.
So, das macht nur Probleme.
Das ist der größte Bullshit ever.
Das heißt, sie müssen sich das Google Cloud SDK runterladen
und jetzt kommt der Hit, dann müssen sie
das entpacken, den Installer,
und müssen in den Trust Store
des
Embedded Pythons für den Installer
das Zertifikat
reinpatchen,
dann können sie den Installer ausführen,
dann können sie das ganze
starten, dann können sie den
G-Cloud Login machen, dann
können sie kubectl nachinstallieren,
dann muss noch
ein Proxy gesetzt werden, und dann
können sie sich
mit kubectl
port forward,
jetzt kommt der Hit, dann können sie sich
mit kubectl anmelden am Kubernetes Cluster
und können mit
kubectl port forward
sich auf
einen Pod connecten
im Kubernetes Cluster.
Okay, soweit?
So, und dieser
Pod im Kubernetes, Moment, Moment, Moment,
Moment, Leute, so einfach,
ist das nicht, so einfach
ist das nicht, nein, nein, nein,
das ist doch, Leute, ihr denkt,
das war's schon, das geht
erst richtig los, das geht erst richtig
los, das geht erst richtig
los, das war's doch lange nicht,
kann man nicht manuell dem einen Cluster,
es geht nicht ums Cluster, es geht ums SSL
Zertifikat, es
ging erstmal darum, dass du die Command Line Tools
installiert bekommst, die du brauchst, um dich zum Cluster
zu connecten, so, so, und dieser
Pod, auf den du dich connecten kannst, du machst
dann, du machst dann quasi
kubectl
auf
vm starte please
blitz, ja, also wer denkt,
dass es das schon gewesen ist, kek wait, Alter,
Alter, vm
please, come on, starten, ja,
new session,
okay, alles klar, so,
und dieser Pod auf der, also die machen dann, das wollte ich
eigentlich, die machen dann kubectl
port forward, sowas
hier in der Richtung machen die dann, guckt, sowas hier,
sinngemäß, sowas in der Richtung,
die machen port forwarding auf
auf, auf einen Pod,
kann's aufn Service machen, aber letztendlich kommt's aufn Pod raus,
also, es, es geht nie aufn
Service auf, wenn man das hier angeben kann, kommt's aufn
Pod raus, kannst du sagen, ich möchte den
lokalen Pod sowieso auf den
Pod, äh, Pod sowieso weiterleiten,
so, das heißt, die können sich mit kubectl
port forward aufn Pod connecten im Kubernetes
Cluster, dieser Pod im Kubernetes Cluster
ist ein Pod, beziehungsweise
in dem Pod läuft ein Container Image,
korrekterweise müsste
man sagen, in dem Pod
läuft ein Container, mit
einem Image, das ich gebaut habe,
und dieses Image
ist ein minimal Debian,
mit nur nem SSH Server und
einem User mit einem
den Entwicklern bekannten Passwort,
das heißt, die können sich dann
quasi auf einen SSH Server
im Name, im IP-Adressbereich
der Kubernetes Pods
eine Verbindung mit kubectl port forward
aufmachen, dann,
also, die machen dann quasi sowas hier in der
Richtung, ich zeig's euch mal, so sinngemäß machen
dann port forward, äh,
dann wissen wir irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie
def container, ähm,
ja, das brauchen wir nicht,
port, port local
port 2222 auf
port 22, ok, sowas in der Richtung
führen die dann aus, und jetzt kommt der Hit,
nachdem sie ja dann weiter
von dort auf die andere Cloud-Infrastruktur
müssen, zum Beispiel haben wir da eine Message-Queue stehen,
wo sie sich hinverbinden müssen, müssen sie
jetzt wiederum
einen Reverse-SSH-Tunnel machen,
über diesen Pod, forwarden Pod,
äh, auf den
Endpunkt beispielsweise von der Message-Queue,
das heißt, danach machen sie sowas hier,
äh, ja, sowas hier in der Richtung, ja,
also, dann kommt dann quasi, ähm,
lokal-Port, nennen wir 8888,
denkt euch mal, das hier ist
der End-, das, denkt euch, das ist die IP
vom Message-Queue-Server, lo-
äh, auf, weiter auf, äh,
dort, port 8888, und das Ganze
geht dann über die
SSH-Verbindung auf
localhost
port 2222,
ja, ok, alles klar,
und dann haben sie lokal eine Verbindung
zur Message-Queue aufgebaut.
Logisch, oder?
So, und das Problem ist jetzt nur,
dass das an sich alleine auch noch nicht
ausreicht, weil die Verbindung
zur Message-Queue an sich
ist ja auch noch
nicht alles. Letztens kam
ein Entwickler zu mir und meinte, ey Max,
ich würde gerne debuggen
eine unserer Anwendungen,
die im Cluster läuft, weil im Cluster
verhält sich die Anwendung anders
als bei ihm auf dem Rechner.
Und jetzt wurde es besonders
abenteuerlich.
Jetzt wurde es super
abenteuerlich. Und zwar
läuft da halt
ein Deployment in Kubernetes
und gegen das aktuelle Image
von ihm, was er da deployed hat,
das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass natürlich
in diesem Image, wie das gebaut wird,
der Debug-Port für,
äh, um sich da mit IntelliJ
zum Beispiel dran zu connecten, überhaupt nicht
offen ist. Das heißt, das erste, was
wir gemacht haben, ist cubectl edit,
von dem Deployment,
blub, ich kann euch das jetzt nicht zeigen,
weil ich hier nichts laufen habe, edit von dem Deployment.
Dort habe ich erstmal eingetragen,
environment-Variable,
ähm, da gab's,
da gibt's irgendeinen Artikel, keine Ahnung,
ja, da muss man dann so ganz spezielle,
ja, so Dinger braucht man dann, ja, okay.
Dann habe ich dann quasi das
Deployment editiert in Kubernetes, habe eine neue
environment-Variable hinzugefügt,
mit diesem Geschiss hier drinnen.
Genau so sieht, so sah das aus,
sowas muss man dann da eintippen.
Dann ist uns aufgefallen,
dass das, dass der Entrypoint
in dem Container-Image
die environment-Variable
gar nicht ausgelesen hat, das heißt, ich habe
im Deployment nochmal den
Entrypoint, also das Command überschrieben,
was der eigentlich ausführt,
der hat dann quasi eine Shell gestartet,
hat die Variable dort interpoliert,
und hat dann Java gestartet,
da drinnen, so.
Dann hatten wir einen Containerlauf im Kubernetes-Cluster
mit dem Debug-Port offen.
Jetzt musste der allerdings an den Debug-Port
drankommen, das heißt, da
bringt ihm dieser Container ja nix,
da musste irgendwie sich Port forwarden
dann auf diesen Container.
Ey, Leute.
Zumindest hat es am Ende
funktioniert, und er konnte sich mit IntelliJ
an den Container verbinden.
Super abartig
weirdes Zeug. Wir machen uns
da mittlerweile schon lustig drüber,
dass halt die einfachsten Sachen bei uns
in der Versicherung dreimal
so lang dauern, weil du
die ganzen Arbeitsverhinderungsmaßnahmen
irgendwie umschiffen musst.
Die Frage ist halt,
was bringen diese ganzen Security-Maßnahmen,
wenn du sie ja doch umgehen kannst,
außer dass sie dich abfacken?
Man weiß es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich sind dann irgendwelche Leute happy.
Aber die Entwickler sind jetzt glücklich,
dass wir einen Weg gefunden haben, das zu machen.
Ist schon echt abenteuerlich, oder?
Also teilweise müssen unsere Entwickler
zwei bis drei Tunnel aufbauen,
damit sie überhaupt ihre Sachen
dann ausprobieren können.
Außer halt lokal.
Lokal auf ihrer Entwicklerkiste geht das.
Aber wie debugst du was, was sich beim ersten Deployment
anders verhält, als bei den lokalen?
Genau dafür sind ja Container da.
Und nachdem das Windows ist, ist da ja auch nichts mit
Docker-Container starten oder so.
Ja, es ist super weird.
Hat das vielleicht was mit Zertifizierung?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich hat das mit irgendwelchen Prüfungen
gesehen zu tun.
Das ist bei uns so krass bürokratisch, Alter.
Ich bin jetzt ja, ich bin noch kein Jahr da.
Ich bin...
Im April bin ich ein Jahr da.
1. April.
Sag mal, ich bin 10 Monate oder so jetzt da.
Also Februar, März halt noch.
Sag mal, ich bin 10 Monate da.
Und ich bin jetzt da wirklich schon...
Das ist schon Alltag für mich.
Also ich denk nicht mehr an den alten Arbeitgeber.
Für mich ist es vollkommen normal,
dass ich da jetzt jeden Tag am Start bin.
Und was man auch daran merkt ist,
dass es normal für mich ist.
Es gibt schon genug Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen.
Zum Beispiel das ganze übertrieben
bürokratische Zeug.
Ja, Pech gehabt.
Sgt. Silver, danke für den Sub.
Übrigens, ich spiel ja
aktuell immer noch
Dark Edge of Camelot auf dem Freeshard
und weißt du was für dort SGT steht?
Da steht da für Siege Tower.
Nicht für Sgt.
Das fällt mir nur gerade auf,
weil die Leute schreiben da immer im Chat
Sgt. Sgt. und das heißt Siege Tower.
Ja, ey, das ist heftig.
Und es ist nicht nur so,
dass es einfach just for fun ist.
Du kriegst ja dann auch...
Oh, ich hab vergessen wie das heißt.
Du kriegst ja dann auch
Minuspunkte, wenn du gewisse Sachen
quasi verkackst und sowas
an Vorgaben.
Da kriegst du richtig Probleme im Zweifelsfall.
Renovate
Renovate ist mega nice.
Ja.
Wär's halt nicht schön, wenn man einfach
Let's Encrypt verwenden könnte.
Was bei uns auch geil ist.
Wisst ihr was ich gemerkt hab?
So Banken und Versicherungen.
Das war ja, als ich bei der Bank gearbeitet habe.
Ist jetzt bei der Versicherung auch so.
Leute, das ist eine gefundene
Geldgrube für Wirtschaftsprüfer.
Wir haben gefühlt
keine Ahnung
alle namenhaften Wirtschaftsprüfer
und
so Consultingläden
bei uns irgendwie rumschwirren.
Und das ist echt
ein so...
Wie soll man sagen? Das ist die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken
für Berater und Prüfer.
So eine Versicherung.
Weil es ist so, dass
viele Abläufe dort
Wie soll man sagen?
Die müssen nicht unbedingt immer geprüft werden.
Aber es ist
immer quasi...
Es wird immer gerne gesehen, dass das geprüft ist.
Das läuft dann so,
dass es irgendeinen neuen Ablauf gibt
und dann sagt dann der Wirtschaftsprüfer
Ah, den würden wir aber gerne
überwachen und den würden wir uns gerne angucken.
Und die Versicherung sagt dann
Jaja, ist gut, macht ihr mal.
Weil es für die Versicherung gut ist, sagen zu können
der Wirtschaftsprüfer war dabei oder der Prüfer war dabei
und für die
Prüfer ist das einfach komplett
die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken.
Die kriegen für jeden Scheiß richtig fett Kohle,
den sie da machen.
Und die sagen bei jedem Furz
Ah, da wären wir gerne dabei.
Und die Versicherung findet es geil, dass die dabei sind.
Weil dann können sie sagen, wir wurden geprüft.
Das ist mega.
Das ist Ultralizenz zum Gelddrucken.
Aber jetzt auch lokal eine richtige Domain mit TLS.
Ja, exzellent, exzellent.
Das ist ein separates Netz.
Das ist alles das gleiche Netz.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Die VMs sind in einem eigenen Netz
und die Clowninfrastruktur ist in einem anderen Netz.
Aber trotzdem müssen die da irgendwie hinkommen.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal schauen,
wo brennt der denn auf Shed Hub?
Wo ist eigentlich mein Wasserglas?
Wo ist das hin?
Die Wasserflasche habe ich da.
Wir sind hier, habe ich noch da, aber das Glas ist weg.
Warte mal, Question.
Wie lange würdest du sagen, hat jemand zum
einarbeiten... Moment, was?
Ich bin zu braindead gerade.
Was möchtest du mir sagen?
Wie lange würdest du sagen,
hat jemand zum einarbeiten...
Achso!
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Wie lange würdest du sagen, hat jemand zum einarbeiten
nach welcher Zeit, welche Leistung...
Also jemand, der nach dem Studium...
Also jemand, der nach dem Studium kommt, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich kann dir sagen, wie lange du Zeit hast,
dich einzuarbeiten,
wenn du irgendwo neu anfängst.
Solange du brauchst.
Blöde Antwort.
Ich weiß, aber
in großen...
Also umso größer und komplizierter das Unternehmen ist,
ist die Einarbeitung nie abgeschlossen.
Leute, die 20 Jahre da sind,
hören
neue Abkürzungen und neue Dinge
und sowas.
Die Einarbeitung ist nie fertig.
Solange du brauchst,
bist du sicher bist in den Sachen,
die du machen musst.
Nehmen wir das doch mal bei mir als Beispiel.
Ich bin jetzt 10 Monate da.
Ich würde sagen, ich blick mittlerweile ganz gut durch.
Aber ich höre an laufende,
in jeder Ecke noch Dinger,
wo ich keinen Plan habe, was es ist.
Und ich weiß, dass es Leuten, die 20 Jahre da sind,
genauso geht.
Ich habe mich nicht daran gehalten.
Ich habe am Anfang
bei jeder zweiten Sache gefragt,
warum machen wir das eigentlich so?
Und da war die Antwort oftmals drauf,
so nach dem Motto,
ja, weil es historisch gewachsen ist,
nicht weil es Sinn macht.
Ich habe zum Beispiel
letztens gesagt, ey, wollen wir nicht
T-Max und Hardtop auf alle Linux Server drauf machen?
Und da meinten die Leute, oh ne.
Ne, aber ich habe gesagt, warum nicht?
Das ist doch mega praktisch.
Gerade T-Max kannst du aus dem Hintergrund laufen lassen.
Und dann habe ich erfahren,
okay, eigentlich finden sie die Idee auch gut,
aber dann müssten sie irgendwie
einen neuen Base-Package-Antrag stellen
und hast du nicht gesehen?
Und da habe ich gesagt, okay, wisst ihr was?
Auf allen Kisten,
die wir jetzt neu aufbauen und die in der Cloud sind
und wo wir das sagen haben, machen wir das einfach.
Und auf den alten Kisten,
die on-prem stehen,
wie das die coolen Leute nennen,
drauf geschissen, ja.
Weil auf unseren Cloud-Kisten können wir
ein bisschen mehr machen, was wir wollen.
Da brauchen wir keinen Basis-Freigabe-Package,
was auch immer-Antrag, um
T-Max installieren zu können.
Und da hatte wirklich jemand gemeint,
Max, jedes Binary bietet Angriffsfläche.
Ja, ist klar.
Ist klar.
Was willst du denn dagegen sagen, Mann?
Warum ist überhaupt
eine Shell installiert?
Du kannst doch jedes Mal
erstmal einen Package-Installer laufen lassen,
wenn du dich remote einloggen lassen musst.
Also eine vorinstallierte Shell bietet
eh enorm viel Angriffsfläche.
Dass da überhaupt SSH offen ist,
bietet auch Angriffsfläche.
Warum ist da überhaupt ein fucking...
Warum ist da ein Betriebssystem drauf, Leute?
Warum ist das nicht
bare-metal booted direkt in die Anwendung?
Versteh ich net.
Alles bloated und Angriffsfläche.
Warum ist das...
Warum hat das überhaupt einen Netzwerkschnecker drin
und ist überhaupt eingeschaltet?
Man könnte es doch nur einschalten,
wenn jemand darauf zugreifen möchte.
Nur über Konsolenkabel wird nur noch.
Nur serielle Verbindungen.
Alles andere ist bloat.
Ich zeig dir, was T-Max ist.
T-Mux. T-Max.
Ich zeig dir, was das ist.
Eigentlich was ganz Nices.
Und zwar, guck mal hier.
Ich habe hier meine Shell, wo ich tippen kann.
Jetzt überleg dir mal,
ich bin nicht lokal bei mir,
sondern ich bin auf einem Server drauf.
Ich erstelle mal kurz eine VM.
Stellt euch vor, das wäre jetzt ein Server, der bei
Google, Microsoft,
Azure,
AWS,
DigitalOcean,
NetCap,
was auch immer läuft.
So.
Ich bin jetzt remote eingeloggt auf meinem Server
in der Cloud.
Und jetzt möchte ich dort
ein paar Sachen ausführen, die ein bisschen länger brauchen.
Und will mir Logs angucken dabei.
Da würde ich sagen,
guck ich mir als erstes mal Log an.
War Log Messages?
Nee, gibt es ja nicht mehr so ein Log.
Fuck, was gibt es da überhaupt noch?
Okay, CloudIn.
Was zum Teufel gibt es?
Achso, ich bin nicht root.
War Log.
So, hä?
Ich habe nichts drauf.
Okay, genau das wollte ich mir
unbedingt angucken.
Okay.
Was zur Hölle?
Ist da nichts drauf?
Okay, CloudIn.
Was ist denn der Output?
Also, ich bin da drauf eingeloggt und möchte mir die Datei hier angucken.
Und nebenbei was machen?
Jetzt ist das Problem,
was muss ich jetzt machen,
dass ich mir die Logdatei angucken kann
und nebenbei auf dem Server was machen?
Das sieht man.
Geht nicht, weil
ich bin eingeloggt und habe hier eine Datei offen.
Das heißt, ich müsste jetzt die Datei zu machen.
Dann würden wir sagen, wir mal ein Programm
starten hier drauf.
Wir starten jetzt mal exemplarisch
eine Schleife, die
einfach
hier immer 1 ausgibt.
So, jetzt kann ich aber, ich würde gerne
das Programm laufen lassen und parallel in die Logs
gucken. Funktioniert nicht. Ja, scheiße war's.
So, und jetzt, da kommt
TMAX ins Spiel.
Uptinstall TMAX.
Uptupdate.
Erstmal vorher.
Da kommt TMAX ins Spiel.
Starten wir jetzt und ihr werdet feststellen, guck mal da.
Jetzt habe ich hier unten so eine Leiste
und ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel
hier drauf meine Schleife starten.
Ja, Steuerung Z Background.
Das ist aber auch kacke. Viele gehen dann ins Sleep
und machen nichts mehr. Das ist alles Schrott.
Das ist viel besser.
Was ist eine gute
Möglichkeit, wie man TMAX in TMAX
handeln kann? Also, wenn du TMAX
lokal hast, ist die beste Möglichkeit dein
Modifier-Key von Steuerung B auf Steuerung A zu legen.
Dann hast du keine Probleme mehr. Ansonsten musst
du halt doppelt escapen.
Steuerung BB und sowas.
So, jetzt kann ich hier oben zum Beispiel
mein Programm starten.
Machen wir exemplarisch mal wieder meine Schleife.
Mein Programm starten.
Hier unten, ich bin immerhin weiter auf dem Server,
kann ich mir die
Systemauslastung angucken.
Da kann ich den zweiten
Tab aufmachen. Hier machen wir
beispielsweise noch die
Systemauslastung
auf. So.
Inklusive I.O.
Und jetzt bin ich immer auf dem gleichen
Server über eine SSH-Connection.
Und
ich kann aber mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig
machen. Und wisst ihr, was das
richtig coole an TMAX ist?
Ja,
was haben wir hier machen wir jetzt noch? Hier machen wir jetzt
abinstall destat.
Oh, das sieht auch noch auf.
So, jetzt haben wir super krasse Überwachung von
unserem eins ausgebenden Programm hier oben.
Das brauchen wir unbedingt. So, jetzt habe ich drei
Sachen parallel laufen. Und wenn
ich jetzt feststelle, ach Mist, ich wollte
doch gerade noch mal hier nach den Logs gucken.
Da habe ich noch eine Stelle. Schnell mache ich ein neues Tab
in TMAX auf.
Gehe nach Warlog und guck mir an,
was hier so abgeht.
Ja, also es ist enorm praktisch.
Und jetzt kommt das Beste an
TMAX. Jetzt bricht
eure Verbindung ab. Oder ihr
geht heim. Und dieser,
geht mal davon aus, hier oben läuft ein Skript, es läuft
40 Stunden und ihr wollt einfach
morgen früh wieder gucken.
Aber ihr wollt jetzt euer Laptop
mit heimnehmen. Oder ihr geht heim
und loggt euch aus, fahrt runter, musst Wartung
machen. Normalerweise würde es jetzt abkacken,
weil eure SSH-Verbindung abkackt.
Nicht so sehr,
wenn ihr jetzt TMAX verwendet.
TMAX könnt ihr euch einfach detachen,
ausloggen
aus der VM. Ihr seht, ich bin
wieder lokal. Ich habe meine SSH,
ja, meine SSH-Verbindung
ist zu. Ich gehe jetzt
pennen, stehe morgen früh wieder auf,
logge mich wieder ein und will nachgucken,
ey, was
macht denn eigentlich diese 40 Stunden Auswertung?
Dann connecte ich mich wieder
per SSH drauf.
Sagt TMAX A, attach mich an die schon
bestehende TMAX Session und kann an der Stelle
weitermachen. Und schon sind wir wieder hier.
Also TMAX ist enorm
praktisch und ich installiere es jetzt einfach auf jedem
Server, auf dem ich mich connecte, nach.
Da brauche ich keinen
Basic Package Approval Prozess,
was auch immer. Ich installiere es einfach nach,
das interessiert keinen.
Und auf allen Cloud-Servern mache ich
was ich will.
Und schon sind wir wieder attached und alles gut.
Ja, das scheint sehr gut zu
sein.
Ja, aber Screen ist abfuck
gegen TMAX.
Ich glaube in Screen,
das einzige, was du in Screen machen
kannst,
ist attach und detachen.
Von dem, was ich euch gezeigt habe.
Kannst du bitte deine
TMAX-Config in ein .files-Repo packen?
Ich habe keine TMAX-Config mehr.
Das ist die default
TMAX-Config hier.
Ich meine, ich habe die VM gerade erst gestartet.
Das ist die ganz normale default Config.
Hier ist nichts.
Oder meinst du das hier unten?
Das hier unten ist kein TMAX.
Das hier unten ist mein Terminal.
Mein Terminal kann
ähnliche Sachen wie TMAX.
Nur das es halt das Terminal kann.
Es kann auch splitten.
Wenn ich die richtige Taste drücke.
Das kann auch splitten.
Das kann zoomen, einzelne Paints.
Du kannst unterschiedliche anklicken.
Du kannst mehrere Tabs aufmachen.
Das ist aber mein Terminal hier unten.
Meine alte TMAX-Config
findest du aber hier.
Die habe ich noch
irgendwo unter Repos
old.files
TMAX-Config
Das war aber auch alles schon.
Das einzige was ich da drinnen
hatte ist, das war als ich TMAX noch lokal
verwendet habe. Auf Servern selbst habe ich
nie eine spezielle TMAX-Config
sondern immer default.
Also hier habe ich auch nichts großartiges
gehabt. Ich habe ein bisschen Farben
gesetzt und die einzigen
zusätzliche, also History-Limit, das du scrollen kannst
habe ich hochgestellt.
Und das einzige was ich wirklich ein bisschen customised
habe ist die
meistbenutzten
Shortcuts.
Ich habe zum Beispiel
Ctrl-Down, Left-Right-Up
habe ich gemappt auf
im Endeffekt hier
durchschalten zwischen den einzelnen
Tabs und zwischen den einzelnen Paints.
Dann habe ich
Ctrl-F im zoomen gemappt
dass es groß wird. Das gleiche habe ich jetzt
bei mir im Terminal auch.
Und ich habe, dass es langsamer
scrollt, wenn ich Shift-Page
abdrücke. Aber wie gesagt, das verwende
ich aktuell gar nicht mehr. Ich verwende
nur mein Terminal noch, was ähnliche Sachen
kann lokal und du nicht TMAX in TMAX brauchst.
Workout-Champ am Start
und auf dem Server nur
default TMAX, sonst nichts.
Aber die alte Config ist hier.
Falls dich das Terminal interessiert, was ich dir
wärmstens nur empfehlen kann,
das Terminal zu verwenden,
weil das ein Extremely POG
Terminal ist,
hast du meine Config
hier.
Westterm, beste.
Heute gibt es keine Nudel mit Lachs.
Und wisst ihr, was das
nice an der Terminal-Config ist?
Also hier, das Programm, was ich hier verwende
für mein Command Line-CAM.
Das ist eine Lua-Config.
Klingt jetzt erstmal bescheuert, warum eine Config
in der Programmiersprache, aber das ist
mega nice, weil du kannst quasi
deine Config teilweise dynamisch
generieren. Und ich hab hier
sowas gebaut, ich weiß, das zeige ich immer.
Aber das finde ich super nice.
Ich hab quasi
auf meine Maus-Buttons gemappt.
Egal wie oft ich die
Maus-Buttons drücke, dass der immer die gleichen Sachen
wiederholt. Also ich kann
meinen Maus-Button 1-99 mal klicken
und er macht dann immer das gleiche.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich einen
Streak habe, einen Mausklick-Streak
von
Maus-Button-Down und zwar den mittleren
Maus-Button von
1-99, sieht man ja hier
Streak-I,
der legt jetzt quasi eine Config an, der legt
das hier quasi 99 mal an. Einmal
mit 1, zweimal, also einmal mittlere
Maustaste gedrückt, zweimal in Folge mittlere Maustaste
gedrückt, dreimal in Folge mittlere Maustaste gedrückt, viermal.
Und dann passiert immer Paste
Primary Selection. Das kennt
man ja schon. Na, das hat ein bisschen rumgebuggt in
Westterm. Ich kann jetzt quasi
hier die Sachen, egal wie oft ich mittlere
Maustaste drücke, pasten.
Und noch viel geiler, man kann sogar
bestimmte Sachen
skripten.
Ich weiß, dass das auch
anderweitig geht unter Linux, aber ich finde
das Verhalten hier beispielsweise ganz nice. Und zwar
was der macht ist, der guckt
was wird heute gemacht?
Eigentlich nur ein bisschen Videos geguckt, aufwachen
und GitHub-Trends gucken.
Wir gucken uns gerade meine
Terminal-Config an. So, hier
wenn ich den rechten Maus-Button
drücke,
dann passiert folgendes.
Der guckt,
ob Text gerade
selected ist im Terminal. Also sowas
hier. Wenn Text
selected ist, dann
bewirkt die mittlere Maustaste,
dass der Text in die
Zwischenablage kopiert wird.
In das Clipboard und in die Primary Selection, weil
wie ihr ja wisst, Linux hat zwei,
eigentlich sogar drei
Zwischenablagen.
Dann wird der Text reinkopiert und
die Selection entfernt. Ist keine
Selection da,
fügt die mittlere Maustaste ein,
er fügt die rechte Maustaste ein.
Heißt im Endeffekt, ich kann jetzt sowas
hier machen,
anklicken, rechte Maustaste
drücken,
jetzt ist es in der Zwischenablage
und nochmal rechte Maustaste drücken
und jetzt wird es gepastet.
Das heißt, ich kann im Endeffekt markieren,
klick klick mit der rechten Maustaste und es wird eingefügt.
Im Prinzip ist es das gleiche
wie mittlere Maustaste, by the way.
Also ähnlich. Mittlere Maustaste
lässt es markiert.
Ich kann jetzt markieren,
Clipboard,
wird Markierung entfernt, rechts
einfügen. Und das ist halt
der Vorteil, wenn man eine Config
hat, die in einer Programmiersprache
erstellt wurde, man kann die dynamisch
generieren. Das ist halt sehr nice.
Das gefällt mir. Also ich war
auch erst skeptisch, warum die ihre Config
in Lua haben, aber das ist nice.
Und ansonsten, wenn man das
nicht machen will,
das ist übrigens auch nicht TMAX, das ist nur
mein Terminal hier.
Bei TMAX kann es sein,
hast du bestimmte Escapes.
Guck mal in meine Config, habe ich vielleicht was zu drinnen.
So, und wenn ihr das alles nicht machen wollt,
könnt ihr auch die Westterm Config
mehr oder weniger benutzen
wie eine traditionelle Config.
Ja, hier.
Disable Default Key Bindings To.
Paint Focus Follows Mouse Falls.
So, Key Page Up soll das machen.
Page Down Shift soll
das machen. Also das ist jetzt die relativ klassische
Relativ klassische Config.
Ja, Windows Padding, das ist hier,
dass ich noch ein bisschen, ne hier,
dass ich hier innen drin noch ein bisschen Rand habe,
dass ich,
also hier links und rechts, dass ein bisschen
Abstand ist. Seht ihr ja, guckt, da ist immer
ein bisschen Abstand hier.
Border Frame, Opacity
im Hintergrund, man sieht leicht, seht ihr leicht
den Hintergrund durchschimmern durch Terminal,
das ist das Setting.
Scroll History und sowas.
Also ihr könnt es auch ganz normal, hier Farbschema,
könnt es auch ganz normal konfigurieren.
Aber es ist, es ist schon nice,
dass die dynamisch
erzeugt werden kann mit Lua, die Config.
Richtig hoge
ist das.
Ja, das ist
ganz wichtig, dass das Terminal written in Rust
ist. Was würden wir machen,
wenn unser Terminal nicht Blazingly Fast wäre?
Ach ja, Chat, heute gibt's
keine, keine Nudeln mit Lachs. Wisst ihr, was es
heute zu essen gibt?
Wer weiß es, ist nicht schwer.
Ihr kommt drauf, an alle
die öfters da sind. Bolognese,
korrekt. Gibt ja nur zwei Sachen.
Chicken, nein, es gibt
ja eigentlich Samstag, äh sonntags gibt's
ja eigentlich nur zwei Varianten, was zu essen gibt.
Okay, was
sind denn die GitHub Trends? Das wollte ich mir seit gefühlt
einer Stunde schon angucken.
Open Spot,
Open Source Spotify Client.
Excellent.
Written in Dart.
Warum denn Dart? Weil
Flutter oder wie?
Oh ja, weil Flutter.
Flutter.
Nitta ist tot?
Echt, warum? Woher weiß man das?
Das ist aber ziemlich sätge,
dass das, dass das tot ist.
Oh, ich seh's grad auf.
Das heißt, Nitta tut nicht mehr?
Wow, auf die Seite geh ich nicht.
Guest accounts have been removed.
Okay, Nitta ist
dead. Das ist aber sehr sätge.
Ne, Eclipse gucken wir uns nicht an.
Nitta is dead. Ja, das
ist blöd. Also,
Flutter war ein alternativer
Twitter Viewer, den ich persönlich sehr nice
fand, weil man das auch gut verwenden
konnte, um sich nicht einloggen zu müssen.
Oh ja.
Elon hat zugeschlagen.
Sätge. Dätge.
Ja, das ist kacke. Hä?
Wie jetzt?
Hat sich irgendjemand die
Domain fritz. fritz.
box
registrieren lassen oder wie?
Who is fritz. box?
Tatsächlich.
Moment.
Warum hat das noch nicht schon früher
jemand gemacht?
Also erstens, warum lässt sich das
auf einmal registrieren? Warum ist das jetzt,
warum ist das, warum ist das jetzt erst?
Warum ist sie jetzt erst?
Gibt es .box erst neu
oder was?
Ach, die ist erst neu.
.boxdomain. Ey, das ist so dumm.
Das ist genauso dumm wie dieses .zip.
Das war ja klar, dass ich
irgendeinen Volldepp
jetzt gleich, wobei das ist kein Volldepp, also
der ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau, dass er die fritz.box
hat registrieren lassen.
Geil. Super. Nice, dass
es eine .boxdomain gibt.
Ey, das ist teilweise
frage ich mich echt, ob die alle nicht nachdenken,
bevor sie neue Domains raushauen.
Das ist einfach hängen geblieben. Okay, also
irgendjemand hat sich fritz.
fritz.box registriert.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt nicht den DNS
von eurer fritz.box verwendet, sodass fritz.box
überschrieben wird oder halt ihr.
das selbst bei euch im DNS eingetragen habt,
dann landet
man jetzt bei fritz.box auf
irgendeinem NFT-Shop
Selling-Kram. Wo ist der
Typ bei Namesilo?
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, was eine
Was kostet kekw.box?
Nicht .com, .box?
Warum kann man .box nicht
kaufen? Was kostet
x.box? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Okay.
Bei boxdomains.
Alter, was ist das für ein
Hyperhipster-Bild?
Okay, x.box.
x.box
ist taken.
Aber was ist kekw.box?
kekw.box ist taken.
Okay, zeigen die einfach nur Mist an?
Was ist das hier .box?
Ist taken.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ich glaub's euch sofort.
Sicherlich.
Ganz bestimmt. Ganz bestimmt
ist das taken.
Mit Sicherheit.
Sofort glaub ich euch das.
Wo war das? Twitter?
Wie war das?
Twitter?
Boxdomains?
Haben die hier irgendwas?
Ein fucking Discord-Server, Mann!
The world's first blockchain native DNS
Ja, wo kann man denn
Boxdomains kaufen?
Also da ja anscheinend schon mal net.
Ich glaub das ist irgendein NFT.
Shit.
searchforyourname.box
kekw.box
Bei 120 Dollar?
Ah, das ist...
Okay, das kann man nur mit Krypto-Stells bezahlen.
Verstehe.
Wie sieht das aus mit twitter.box?
Oh, ist unavailable. Shit.
Wie sieht das aus mit
x.box?
PlayStation.box
It is available. Okay.
maxfps.box
Ja, das dachte ich mal, das werde ich mir nicht kaufen.
Wozu? Gibt es text.box?
Ne, andere waren auch schon schlauer.
Twitch.box
Ah, ah, okay.
Available. Drop.box
Das haben die sich bestimmt registrieren lassen.
Wobblords.box
Ja, das gibt es.
Interessant.
Krypto-Wallet-Stells
Alles klar.
Was man nicht alles lernt.
Fritz.box.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Oh, Mann.
Okay, also ich wollte eigentlich gucken, was trendet
auf GitHub seit einer Stunde.
Dönerbox.
Ey, das ist eine geile Idee. Sekunde.
Ich meine Umlaute, ne? Warum nicht?
Döner.
Oh, ne.
Döner.box gibt es noch.
Chat, wie macht man
Umlaute in der Domain?
Da gibt es doch so eine
Emoji-Domains.
Wie kann man diesen Campbell encoden?
Da gibt es doch so einen
Unicode-Converter.
Ja, genau.
Das da.
Und jetzt?
Ist frei.
Nur, nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, Chat.
Ich habe das noch nie verwendet.
Moment, das habe ich jetzt irgendwie.
Wenn ich mir das jetzt kaufen würde,
dann könnte man Döner.box
aufrufen oder wie ist das?
Oder muss das der DNS irgendwie umwandeln
und unterstützen?
Ich habe mich damit noch nie beschäftigt.
Ja, es gibt ja auch
Emoji-Domains und sowas mittlerweile schon.
Nudelbox.
Gibt es das noch?
Ne, das will ich nicht.
Ich will nicht Nudelbox.
Ich will Nudel mit
Lachs-Box.
Ist auch noch frei.
Asia, das ist bestimmt schon weg.
Oh.
Achso.
Wie funktioniert das?
Okay, man muss sein Wallet connecten.
Coinbase.
Und dann kann man nur mit
Crypto-Stells bezahlen anscheinend.
Boah.
Mal überlegen, was für eine .box-Domain
ich mir kaufen kann.
Wie sieht das eigentlich mit
sas.box aus?
Gibt es das auch noch?
Leute, wird Zeit, dass wir uns ein Crypto-Wallet
anlegen und mal eine Runde
Box-Domains kaufen.
So, aber was trennt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich auf
Github? Wir kommen da heute echt nicht dazu.
Ja, komisches
komisches AI-Zeug.
Raster, das kennen wir schon.
AI, AI, AI,
AI, AI, AI.
AI.
jasoncrack.com
Innovative und
Open-Source-Visualisation-Application.
Okay, blablabla.
GRPC Go.
Das es das in Go gibt,
hätte mich jetzt auch...
Hätte es das nicht in Go gegeben, hätte mich auch schwer gewundert.
Oh, nichts.
IPTV, okay.
Bestimmt furchtbar offizielle
IPTV-Streamlinks,
wenn ich das Repo mir so angucke.
Ja, nicht so spannend, oder?
Lass uns mal ganz schnell
noch gucken, was es denn in der .net-Welt
gibt. Ah ja, Afrikaans.
Nein.
Wenn das die Sharp-Welt neu ist, so gibt...
Also, was war Expo, habe ich jetzt gar nicht
irgendwie über... Open-Source-Plattform
Mac-Universe... Ah, React.
Das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich mir sogar schon mal angeguckt.
War Expo nicht so ein Ding,
wo du früher einfacher deine
React-Apps auf ein iPhone sideloaden
konntest, weil es eine Expo-App gab,
die dann quasi nur deinen Code ausgeführt
hat, was dann Apple irgendwann
entfernt hat? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass
das noch gibt.
Okay, in der .net-Welt
wieder nichts Spannendes. Also,
wenn diese Woche Maui wieder trendet,
glaube ich echt, dass es geboostet von Microsoft
einfach nur, weil
niemand, der bei Sin ist, irgendwie Maui benutzt.
Shit-Extensions.
Wisst ihr, woran
erkennt man Noobs?
Noobs erkennt man daran,
dass sie für Git irgendwelche GUI-Tools
verwenden. Habe ich schon oft genug gesagt.
Und der Chat ist ja da immer komplett anderer Meinung.
Jetzt kommen gleich... Jetzt spawnen gleich
wieder die Leute im Chat, die sagen,
aber Max, ich verwende immer
GUI-Tools mit Git. Ich hatte damit noch
nie Probleme. GUI-Tools beste.
Aber für mich ist Command Line
Git das einzig wahre.
Wo ich es mir gefallen lasse, ist
beispielsweise vielleicht bei etwas längeren
Merge-Konflikten,
dass ich sage,
ja, okay, da kann man
ein GUI-Tool verwenden.
Man kann aber auch Wimdiv verwenden.
Chat, Merge-Konflikte.
Wimdiv oder GUI-Tool?
Ganz ehrlich, ich verwende
eigentlich auch nicht Wimdiv, weil
Wimdiv, keine Ahnung, Wimdiv checke ich nicht.
Man kann auch Merge-Konflikte einfach
bei Texteditor von Hand lösen.
Also hier übertreiben das die .NET-Leute
echt richtig. Ich habe mir mal so einen Vortrag
angeguckt zu so einem Clean-Architecture-Projekt
und
das war so ultra plaud
einfach nur.
Da hat irgendeiner dann...
Ist dann irgendeiner auf die Idee gekommen,
dass man DateTime nicht verwenden darf,
sondern ein eigenes IDateTime-Interview
Interface dafür braucht, weil DateTime...
Ich denke mir so, what the fuck, ich meine
DateTime ist Standard-Framework-Library-Gramm.
Warum sollte man das nicht verwenden?
Also,
wenn man unbedingt aus
50 Zeilen 800 Zeilen machen
will für kleine Projekte, dann
kann man die ja auch mit Clean-Architecture machen.
Ansonsten, für größere Sachen ist
das natürlich sinnvoll. Richtig,
genau sehe ich auch so. Ne, wenn du
größere Sachen hast, gerade wenn du Sachen hast,
wo unterschiedliche Leute im Team
an unterschiedlichen Sachen und so, macht das halt schon
Sinn. Aber so dieses
jedes Projekt, was ich erstelle, ist nur noch Clean-Architecture
ist halt bescheuert.
Außerdem ist das eindeutig gemünzt auf Web-Anwendungen.
Steht ja sogar da.
Oder Web-Backends.
PEAS!
Achso, das Zeug hier da.
Was ist das? Ist das ein Game?
Ne.
Ist das irgendein Cheating, Cheat, Cheat,
Cheat-Menü?
Was bin ich hier sehend, Leute?
Ist das...
Ist das irgendein Cheating-Tool?
Aber für was?
Was ist das?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich da sehe.
Was ist das für ein Game?
Lethal Company.
Was? Kenn ich nicht.
Coop.
Moment, ist das ein Multiplayer-Game?
Ein Multiplayer-Coop-Game, in dem die Leute
dann auch noch cheaten. Okay.
Naja gut, nachdem es ein Coop-Game ist,
und man sich dann quasi nur sich
und seinen Kollegen den Spaß verdirbt,
finde ich das okay.
Gerade wenn man mal Sachen ausprobieren will,
die das nicht so vorsieht,
glaube ich, dass es nicht so wild ist.
Also ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme
mit Cheats, wenn es Singleplayer-Games sind,
Coop-Games.
Wenn es Competitive-Multiplayer-Games sind,
dann ist das natürlich problematisch.
Avalonia trendet, zu Recht.
Und ich hoffe, das trendet immer weiter
und Maui trendet nicht, weil Maui Schrott ist
und Avalonia POG.
Open-RP-based-HDP-Client-Code-Generator.
Ist ja schön.
Fiat, weil ich muss ja irgendwann auch da mal
irgendwann wieder weiterentwickeln.
Fiat hat natürlich keine Open-RP-Definition.
Ist ja klar.
Maui trendet nicht.
Ich bin happy.
Ja, genau.
Drei Stunden Design-Patterns
und Best-Practice-Patterns
und hast nicht gesehen,
damit der Hello World laufen ist.
Okay, also.
Gucken wir uns mal ein paar Videos an.
Wir sind jetzt fast eine Stunde 45 on.
Ich habe ohne Pause dummes Zeug
geschwätzt.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein paar Witz an.
Ich finde es schön, dass YouTube mir immer mehr
meine eigenen Videos empfiehlt,
was ich sehr nice finde.
Gaming-Stream ohne lag.
Moonlight-Sunshine im Test.
Habe ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Schon vor Jahren.
Das gibt es ja schon eine ganze Weile.
Was ist eigentlich mit den Shorts wieder los?
Wisst ihr, ich bin...
Also es gibt zwei Sachen,
die mag ich nicht,
die mag ich regelrecht.
Das eine sind Clown-Emojis.
Clown-Emojis sind einfach in so vielen Bereichen
negativ vorbehalten.
Sobald ich ein Clown-Emoji sehe,
gucke ich mir das nicht an.
Und wisst ihr, was das andere ist,
was ich nicht mag?
In Chats.
Es gibt zwei Sachen.
Clown-Emoji mag ich nicht.
Ja, ist klar, dass der Chat jetzt wieder loslegen muss.
Clown-Emojis mag ich nicht.
Und was ich auch nicht mag,
ich kann ihn...
Nicht die Twitch-Variante, die Twitch-Variante geht ja noch.
Ich kann diesen in genau dieser Variante,
ich kann ihn nicht ab.
Widerlich, ne?
Chat, ich hab mal...
Okay, okay.
Wir müssen eine ganz wichtige
Umfrage machen.
Was ist schlimmer?
Ich mach mal eine Umfrage.
Was
ist schlimmer?
Clown vs.
Clown-Smiley.
YouTube-Emotes sind einfach nur schlecht.
Alter, der Windows-11-Clown-Smiley
sieht da schon ein bisschen gestört aus, oder?
Ich...
Den mag ich.
Den benutze ich selbst auch.
Ich lerne gerade...
Was?
Für die Uni und die Unterricht noch immer
Netzwerklassen. Hast du die jemals in
freier Wildbahn gesehen?
Ja.
Es ist ja heute zum
größten Teil Zitre.
Aber im Prinzip spielen sich die
privaten Sachen
ja immer noch in
den dafür vorgesehenen privaten Netzen ab.
Ja.
Auch wenn du nicht hardcodet immer nur
slash24
slash...
Ja.
Also zumindest zu wissen,
von wo bis wo
private IP-Ranges sind, ist doch nicht verkehrt.
Ich sehe es anders.
Ich finde den auch scheiße, aber der regt mich
am allermeisten auf.
Ich kann das nicht ab...
Beispiel.
Letztens Chat in einem MMO gehabt.
Ja.
Leute joinen in die Gruppe.
Ich weiß, das ist ein Deutscher.
Und ich schreibe in Chat, Moin.
Und was antwortet er darauf?
Was soll die scheiß Antwort, Mann?
Das triggert mich ultra.
Ich hasse diesen Smiley einfach nur.
Das ist so...
Ich kriege immer Anfälle, wenn ich den sehe
Was ist...
Was ist das für eine Antwort auf Moin, Mann?
Soll er lieber...
Soll er die Klappe halten und nichts schreiben?
Zwinker.
Ich kann das...
Da kannst du so viel reininterpretieren.
Aber ich interpretiere da immer nur das Negativste rein.
Ah.
Chat.
Habe ich vergessen?
Wo waren wir gerade stehen geblieben?
Keine Ahnung. Komische Smilies.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Was soll ich sagen?
Zumindest mag ich...
Ah, jetzt vergessen.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier noch?
The day before die Geschichte einer Spiel...
Oh ne, jetzt bloß nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Den kann man sich immer gucken.
Die sind immer angenehm.
Game Streaming ohne Leck.
Also ich habe Moonlight und Sunshine schon vor einer ganzen Weile ausprobiert.
Nummer 2, was sich auf YouTube triggert?
Wollte ich das sagen?
Ne.
Oder?
Ich habe das vor einer ganzen Weile ausprobiert, Moonlight und Sunshine.
Beziehungsweise Moonlight fast damals.
Moonlight ist ja nur der Client.
Soweit ich das weiß.
Also im Prinzip ist Moonlight
eine Reimplementierung
von Nvidia Game Stream.
Wolltest du was über Shorts generell sagen?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt Game Streaming ohne Leck an.
Ich habe das vor einer ganzen Weile ausprobiert.
Und da war das wirklich sehr, sehr nice.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist mein PC im Arbeitszimmer.
Und das ist mein Fernseher 3 Räume weit.
Kann man mit Moonlight Sunshine
mittlerweile auch gescheit
den kompletten Desktop streamen?
Und auf dem Fernseher spiele ich
Cyberpunk 2077 in 4K
HDR.
Auch Linux auf Windows?
Geht auch ohne spürbare Verzögerung.
Okay, sorry. Wahrscheinlich alles außer Wayland, oder?
Wieder mal.
Und jetzt kommt's.
An dem Fernseher hängen überhaupt keine Videokabel.
Das Spiel läuft auf meinem PC
und wird übers interne Netz
direkt auf den TV gestreamt.
Von einer App, die direkt auf dem Fernseher läuft.
Und um es muss auch der Controller
nicht mit dem PC gekoppelt sein,
sondern einfach nur mit dem Fernseher.
In diesem Video erkläre ich euch,
wie dieses Kunststück funktioniert.
Und wenn ihr keinen kompatiblen LG-Fernseher habt,
könnt ihr das auch einfach über ein Raspi,
ein Steam Deck, ein Handy,
ein Alpin Client, ein Notebook
oder ein Tablet springen.
Und das auch, weil da kommt das ja mit
unter anderem her.
Natürlich ist das auch alles
Open Source und kostenlos.
Also in meiner App für Android TV wird's ja schon geben.
... und Sunshine.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Server,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Blödes Intro, Alter.
Ja, Streaming
vom PC ist praktisch.
VPNs sind ebenfalls praktisch.
Damit lässt sich nämlich Geld sparen.
Ah, NordVPN.
Damit kann man sich ganz einfach
in beliebige Länder tunneln.
Und wenn man dann auf irgendeine Website geht,
denkt die, man ist in eben diesem anderen Land.
Damit kann man zum Beispiel Sachen bestellen,
die...
Ja, NordVPN wollte bei mir Werbung machen.
Aber dann haben sie entdeckt,
das habe ich euch jetzt schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
NordVPN wollte bei mir Werbung machen
und wir waren uns auch schon einig.
Eigentlich ganz nicer Deal.
Und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen,
der Max
hat bei sich auf dem Kanal
ein Video,
das sich nennt
Lügen der VPN-Anbieter.
Und da geht es gar nicht
explizit um
NordVPN,
sondern so allgemein
um...
Okay, NordVPN
ist auf dem Thumbnail.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
NordVPN ist auf dem Thumbnail drauf.
Okay, okay.
Und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen,
ich habe ein Video und das hat ihnen nicht gefallen.
Und dann wollten sie nicht mehr.
Und sie haben gesagt, ja,
wir freuen uns über die Kooperation
und freuen uns,
bald starten zu können.
Aber das haben die so nebensächlich
erwähnt, so nach dem Motto.
Also so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist ja ganz toll
und wir freuen uns darüber
und wir möchten auch bald starten
und das ist alles ganz toll
und wir sind super hyped.
Wir haben da aber ein Video gefunden.
Könntest du das bitte noch entfernen?
Und wann denkst du denn hochzuladen?
So nach dem Motto.
Wann denkst du denn die Kooperation hochzuladen?
Das haben die so in einem ganz kleinen Nebensatz erwähnt,
dass die wollen, dass ich mein Video lösche.
So nach dem Motto, ja, alles
alles klar,
alles gut, aber
löscht doch mal dein Video.
Wann willst du denn unsere Kooperation starten?
Das macht ne Agentur, das war nicht NordVPN.
Das war nicht NordVPN direkt.
Und da habe ich dann
nur geschaut, das starten wir halt gar nicht.
Es löscht doch keine Videos, Alter.
... hierzulande nicht erhältlich sind,
andere Filme und Serien, zum Beispiel auf Netflix gucken.
Man kann auch CT 3003.
Werbung Ende.
Ja, ich bin mir echt ziemlich sicher,
dass viele von euch das Problem kennen.
Ihr habt einen PC in Raum A,
aber ihr wollt das Ding in Raum B nutzen,
wo ihr zum Beispiel ein großes Display
wie nen Fernseher habt.
Oder ihr wollt halt auf irgendwas Tragbarem
euer PC-Game beitragen.
Also, es war nicht
genug Kohle, dass ich mein Video gelöscht hätte.
Ne, da muss mir aber eh schon
einer enorm viel Kohle bezahlen,
dass ich alte Videos
lösche. Sogar Activision
wollte damals, dass ich ein altes Video lösche,
dass sie mit mir irgendwie zusammenarbeiten
für irgendwie Call of Duty Zeug vor
zig Jahren. Hab ich auch nicht gemacht.
Ich lösche
prinzipiell keine Videos, nur weil's irgendjemand
nicht gefällt und der
dann sagt, dann gibt's halt kein Geld, dann haben sie Pech.
Dann mach ich halt nix. Ich bin ja da nicht drauf angewiesen.
Oder so. Und meistens
sind diese Videos
ja nicht, weil's mir danach
wäre, irgendwas zu flamen,
sondern weil sie Scheiße gebaut haben
oder halt wirklich irgendwas kacke ist.
Ne,
wisst ihr, was noch geiler wär?
Video auf Privatstellen,
Kooperation machen,
und wenn die Kooperation
rum ist, das Video wieder öffentlich.
Das ist eigentlich
mega big brain.
Danach checken die das noch
eh nicht.
Das hätt ich eigentlich machen müssen, ja.
Das wär's doch.
NordVPN Geld abgreifen und danach das Video wieder
public stellen. Eigentlich ist das
die Idee.
Und selbst wenn, was wollen sie machen?
Also bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so, dass
ich in meinem Studio, man könnte auch
Arbeitszimmer oder Rumpelbude
sagen, einen richtig guten PC stehen
hab. Wer diesen Channel hier verfolgt, weiß,
die hab ich ja selbst zusammengebaut, die Kiste.
Ja, aber ich sitz dann den ganzen Tag hier schon
und will dann natürlich abends nicht
auch noch hier in meiner Freizeit
rumhängen, sondern würde dann halt gerne
im Wohnzimmer auf dem Sofa chillen.
Aber das ist halt drei Zimmer weiter.
Und der PC ist sehr schwer. Aber
im Wohnzimmer steht halt auch ein 65 Zoll
OLED, der für viele Spiele eh
besser geeignet ist, als mein kleiner
27 Zoll PC-Monitor.
So, und deshalb hab ich mich jetzt mal
Ja, je nachdem, je nachdem.
Ich mag ja spielen
an nem nicht allzu großen Monitor.
Wo das wirklich cool ist,
wo ich beispielsweise auch schon ausprobiert hab,
ist, die
letzten Teile hab ich nicht gespielt,
aber ältere Assassin's Creed-Spiele,
die kommen richtig zur Geltung
oder kamen richtig zur Geltung auf dem großen
Display. Ja, das stimmt. Aber die meisten
Sachen, die ich spiele, da will ich hier in meinem
Arbeitszimmer vorm Rechner sitzen, vorm PC,
240 Hertz
Moni... äh,
360 Hertz Monitor? Ne, 240
Hertz Monitor. Ich glaub, abgegradet
auf 360 Hertz hatte ich nie.
Und werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Da hol ich mir lieber ein OLED-Display.
Wo sieht man denn noch einmal unter
Windows hier die
Lens vs. Zombies? Alles klar.
Advanced Display Information?
140 Hertz.
Okay.
140...
240, nicht 140 Hertz.
240 Hertz.
Das ist halt einfach nice. Das hast du auf dem Fernsehen nicht.
Diese Sachen mit
Fernseh-240 Hertz ist ja oftmals fake,
weil Zwischenbildberechnung nicht wirklich 240 Hertz ist.
...
Ja, das ist...
Also, bei Fernsehern ist diese Hertz-Angabe
oftmals ultra fake und bezieht
sich nicht auf die wirkliche Refresh-Rate,
sondern auf die Refresh-Rate
inklusive Zwischenbildberechnung.
Oder ist das ein...
Meinen die das ernst, ja?
Asus ROG OLED mit
480 Hertz. Nice, das
brauch ich. Der hat bestimmt auch wieder Lüfter
drinne. Für Asus ist es ja mittlerweile
normal, das Monitor... Okay, normal nicht, aber
auch kein... sagen wir mal so,
bei Asus kommt es durchaus auch mal vor,
dass Monitore Lüfter haben.
Und der hat bestimmt auch einen Lüfter.
Wahrscheinlich kostet der Monitor dann aber
4000 Euro oder so.
Hier soll sich jederzeit von 4K
UHD-Auflösung mit 240 Hertz
auf Full HD
mit
480 Hertz. Wisst ihr, was ich cool finde?
Es hat ewig gedauert. Die Frage habe ich
dem
Asus
Marketing-Mensch gestellt auf der
ESL One in Köln.
Wann es denn sowas geben wird?
Da...
dauert noch ein bisschen, aber dass das
bisschen quasi 8 Jahre sind,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
6 Jahre oder so.
Das ist schon mal nice.
Full HD
480 Hertz.
Das ist natürlich echt
nur was für
super
competitive Games
in ultra low
settings.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher,
ich meine, CS läuft überall,
aber ich bin mir nicht mal sicher,
ob das neue CS überhaupt
mit 480 Hertz gescheit läuft.
Wobei doch, wird das machen.
Wird das machen, weil
die meisten Leute spielen das ja
noch nicht mal auf Full HD.
Die spielen das ja auf niedrigsten Settings
in, frag mich net,
für scheppen Oldschool-Auflösung.
Und wahrscheinlich rendert das mit
wie groß ist der Monitor?
39 Zoll
ist mir persönlich auch zu fett.
Aber man muss halt sagen,
39 Zoll macht schon
Sinn bei einem 4K-Monitor.
Aber das ist mir für meinen Schreibtisch
zu groß.
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt...
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
26 Zoll oder so?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich würde nachgucken, wenn an meinem Monitor was dranstehen würde.
Hab ich nicht irgendein Bild?
Ja.
Ist das der?
25 Zoll, ja.
Den habe ich aktuell.
Der, nicht funktioniert.
Aber ich habe nicht diese komischen
Seitenteile dran.
So, das Ding, das Teil habe ich
aktuell. Seit einer Weile.
240 Hertz.
Ist nicht das geilste Panel, aber
ist ja auch nur ein Full-HD-Monitor.
Der nächste Monitor
wird dann ein bisschen, vielleicht minimal
größer, aber mit mehr Auflösung.
Und dann auch OLED.
Und 240 Hertz.
Oder vielleicht sogar 480,
wenn ich noch ein bisschen warte.
So als Upgrade sehr nice.
Ja, aber cool.
Dass es da langsam noch ein paar Innovationen
gibt. Okay, weiter.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein alter Hut.
Arzi, danke schön für den Sub.
Sgt. Silver Pog-Subscription
habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Der Wubblos hat einen Sub gegiftet.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Was der Wubblos so macht.
Der hat mit dem 17er Valve
die Steam Link Hardware ausgebracht.
Die hat genau das gemacht.
Das kleine Kistchen per HDMI
mit dem Kästchen gekoppelt
und dann vom PC übers Netz gestreamt.
Drei Jahre später war es dann aber schon wieder vorbei
mit der Steam Link Hardware.
Und die Technik ist jetzt einfach in Steam integriert.
Und heißt jetzt Remote Play.
Aber zumindest bei mir hat das immer nur so
halb gut funktioniert.
Also irgendwas hat da früher immer gehakt, geruckelt.
Was jetzt aber nicht heißen soll,
dass es auch so sein muss.
Also ich möchte Steam Remote Play jetzt auch nicht dissen,
sondern sage nur, Moonlight und Sunshine
haben bei mir deutlich besser.
Also bei mir kann ich dir sagen,
mein Monitor ist ungefähr...
Habe ich irgendwas zu messen?
Ich kann es dir sagen,
mein Monitor ist ziemlich genau
eine Unterarmlänge entfernt von meiner Tastatur.
Also ziemlich nah dran.
Mit der Software, also Moonlight und Sunshine,
die ich in diesem Video vorstelle,
habe ich auf meinem Setup wirklich so gut wie keine Probleme gehabt.
Kurzer Einschub.
Ich liste das hier jetzt mal so detailliert wie möglich auf,
weil diese Streaming-Sachen
sehr unterschiedlich auf unterschiedlichen Systemen laufen.
Da sind dann solche konkreten Angaben ganz praktisch.
Also auf der Host-Seite
habe ich einen Windows 11 PC
mit AMD
7950X3D.
Ist leistungstechnisch ungefähr das,
was ich auch habe.
Wobei seine CPU für Games ein bisschen
ein Ticken schneller ist.
Aber auch ein Jahr neuer.
Und auf der kleinen Seite
habe ich einen Android 65 CX Fernseher
von 2020
mit direkt mit dem TV über Bluetooth
gekoppelten PS5 Dualsense Gamecontroller.
Auf dem Fernseher
läuft die LG WebOS App
von Moonlight,
also da ist der Developer Mode erforderlich,
dazu später mehr.
Im Netz hängen alle Geräte per LAN-Kabel
gekoppelt über D-Link DGS-Switches
an einer Fritzbox 6690.
Ich habe damit
mehrere Stunden auf meinem Fernseher
vom PC gestreamt gespielt
und ganz ehrlich, hätte man mir gesagt,
der PC ist direkt per Kabel ans TV eingeschlafen,
hätte ich das auch geglaubt.
Ich habe keine Verzögerung bei der Steuerung
festgestellt und auch keine Bildfehler
oder Artefakte gesehen.
Das einzige, hin und wieder stoppte der Ton
mal für eine Viertelsekunde oder so.
Aber da hätte ich zuerst eh gedacht,
dass es halt am Spiel liegt.
Zumal es auch noch Cyberpunk ist.
Bei mehreren Spielen auf,
also liegt das wohl ziemlich sicher am Streaming.
Aber wirklich doll gestört hat mich das nicht.
Also insgesamt ist das mit Abstand
die beste Qualität,
die ich bislang beim Thema Spielestreaming
so gesehen habe.
Und ich habe auch schon sehr intensiv
mit anderen Streaminglösungen wie damals
Google Stadia und zum Beispiel Shadow
herum experimentiert.
Dazu muss ich jetzt einfach nochmal
Einfach weil Stadia ist.
Stadia und zum Beispiel Shadow
herum experimentiert.
Bei Stadia und Shadow
und auch bei dem GeForce Streamingdienst,
da stehen die Gaming-PCs halt weit entfernt
in irgendwelchen Rechenzentren
und halt nicht nur 3 Zimmer weiter.
Also die Daten müssen prinzipbedingt
längere Wege zurücklegen.
Aber das Prinzip ist das gleiche.
Der Client schickt Befehle von Controller
oder Maus und Tastatur übers Netz
an einen Server und der berechnet Bild und Ton
und schickt die Daten als Video
und Audio-Stream zurück an den Client.
Ja und was ist denn jetzt
Moonlight und Sunshine?
Das sind beides kostenlose Umsource-Projekte.
Jaja, Stadia, der Stadia-Typ
hat, um da mal dran zu erinnern
Google Stadia
Weiß nicht, ob man das
noch findet.
Negativ-Latency
Ja, man findet halt
die offizielle Aussage von dem Typ nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Also Google Stadia
hat ja behauptet, bei ihnen gäbe es
Negativ-Latency, weil das so geil ist.
Das ist weird.
Die haben ja dann
ein bisschen zurückgerudert, haben das erklärt
und haben gesagt, ja, aber bei Multiplayer-Spielen
ist es ja so,
dadurch, dass dann quasi nur noch
der In- und Output gestreamt wird
zum Spieler
und die Spiele selbst
im gleichen Rechenzentrum laufen
wie dann quasi auch die Clients
laufen, dann hat man quasi weniger Latency
wie wenn alles bei einem daheim laufen würde.
Das wollten sie damit sagen.
Man hat dann quasi Negativ-Latency.
Was halt echt affig ausgedrückt war.
Und wie gut Stadia geklappt hat, sieht man ja.
Also das Programm läuft
auf dem Server, also dem Rechner.
Ich wusste von Anfang an, dass Stadia ein Griff ins Klo wird.
... der Bild und Ton berechnet.
Moonlight ist der Client,
der empfängt den Video- und Audio-Stream
von Sunshine
und schickt da auch die Controller-Befehle hin.
Ursprünglich war Moonlight
ein Hack für Nvidias Game-Stream.
Daher kenn ich das auch und da hab ich das auch ausprobiert mit.
Also damit man das auch mit
anderen Geräten als mit dem
Nvidia Shield benutzen kann. Richtig.
Game-Stream ist genau das, was ich gerade
erklärt habe, nur eben von Nvidia.
Eingebacken in den Grafikkarten.
Und mittlerweile nicht mehr supportet,
soweit ich weiß.
Und die wollten halt damals ihre Shield-Hardware
verkaufen, denn zuerst hat das nur damit funktioniert.
Also der Gaming-PC brauchte
eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte und als Client
konnte man nur so eine Nvidia Shield-Box
verwenden. Mit dem Moonlight-Projekt
konnte man das Ganze dann auch ohne Shield
verwenden. Also zum Beispiel auf Raspis
oder Tablets. Nvidia hat aber jetzt künstlich
die Entwicklung von Game-Stream
eingestellt. Verstehe ich gar nicht. Das war ein
richtig nice Feature. Also das wird auch
nicht weiterentwickelt. Stand heute ist die
Game-Stream-Funktion zwar immer noch im
Nvidia-Treiber zu finden, aber auf
Nvidia Shields wird bzw.
wurde die Funktion entfernt.
Aber das ist ja auch alles gar nicht schlimm, denn es
gibt ja Sunshine. Und diese
Open-Source-Software bildet Game-Stream
nicht nur nach, sondern hat auch noch
gegenüber Game-Stream einige Vorteile.
Vor allem läuft sie nicht nur auf
Nvidia-Grafikkarten, sondern auch auf AMD
oder Intel-Grafikkarte.
Und sie läuft auch nicht nur unter Windows,
sondern auch unter Linux und MacOS.
Während Sunshine anfangs noch nicht ganz
so gut funktionierte wie Game-Stream,
ist das inzwischen zumindest bei unseren Tests
mindestens genauso gut.
Die Installation. Sunshine ist
super leicht zu installieren. Einfach hier
zum Beispiel auf GitHub die für euer System
passende Version runterladen. Also hier
unter Windows, also diese hier. Und einfach
doppelklicken zum Installieren.
Dann öffnet sich eine Seite im Browser, wo
ihr einmal Login und Passwort festlegen
müsst. Eventuell warnt euch euer Browser,
dass ihr euch mit einer unsicheren Seite
verbindet. Das müsst ihr dann einmal erlauben.
Wenn ihr eingeloggt seid, könnt ihr Sunshine
konfigurieren. Ich würde euch
raten, das alles erstmal auf den Voreinstellungen
zu lassen. Könnt ihr Sunshine...
Das ist ne Bootstrap-Webseite, oder?
Das sieht so ultra Bootstrap-y aus.
Das Bootstrap, Leute.
...konfigurieren.
Ich würde euch raten, das alles erstmal
auf den Voreinstellungen zu lassen.
Tweaken könnt ihr das später immer noch.
Das einzige, was wichtig ist, hier unter
Applications könnt ihr die Spiele oder
Programme eintragen, die ihr dann direkt
in Moonlight starten wollt.
Voreingestellt ist bei Sunshine Desktop
und Steam. Also halt einfach euer Desktop,
klar, und Steam im
Big Picture Modus. Wenn ihr da manuell eine
Software reinwerfen wollt, auf Add New
klicken, hier oben bei Application Name
den Namen des Spiels reinschreiben
und bei Detached Commands
dann einfach den kompletten Pfad
zur ausführbaren Datei rein.
Um den Pfad easy zu kopieren, einfach
Shift und Rechtsklick auf die
Echse des Spiels und dann auf
die Echse des Spiels.
Shift plus Rechtsklick.
Moment, überspringt Shift plus Rechtsklick
etwa dieses dumme neue
Menü?
Ah!
Das kannte ich ja noch gar nicht.
Es gibt jetzt einen Shortcut, um dieses dumme
neue Menü zu überspringen.
Wo ich nicht weiß, warum es überhaupt
da ist, ehrlich gesagt.
What's using this file?
Was bin ich hier am?
High Locksmith.
What? Ah, ist das Powerpoint?
Powertoys, die ich hier am Start habe?
Ne. Habe aber Powertoys
doch gar nicht an.
Powertoys. Settings.
Äh, ich mach mal kurz alles
aus.
Weil ich eigentlich
davon, wenn überhaupt,
nur die Keyboard
Shortcuts verwende.
Einfügen und einmal
auf das grüne Plus klicken.
Und ist das jetzt weg, wenn ich es wieder mal anklicke?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Bei Image unten könnt ihr
Find Cover klicken und dann
Oh, das ist ja cool, dass sie das gleich wieder eingebaut haben.
Das geht dann zu irgendeiner
Spiele-Datenbank und lädt sich ein Bild runter dazu.
Dann heißt es automatisch ein passendes Bild.
Save klicken, fertig.
Falls Sunshine direkt beim Systemstart
starten soll, geht ihr bei laufendem
Sunshine unter Windows in
Dienste, Windows-Taste und dann halt
Dienste eingeben und sucht beim
Buchstaben S den Sunshine-Service.
Und hier dann unter Eigenschaften
Starttyp automatisch auswählen.
Zack. Weil Windows logisch ist.
Das ist vor allem dann sinnvoll,
wenn ihr über den Moonlight-Client
euren PC
Ok, ganz ehrlich.
Ob ich jetzt Services
Start automatisch sage oder System
CTL Enable Service.
Eigentlich macht es keinen großen Unterschied.
... über Wake online
hochfahren wollt. Tatsächlich habe ich das
bei mir so laufen und das funktioniert auch
einwandfrei. Weil ich kein Auto-Login
in Windows einstellen will, muss ich dann nur
über den Moonlight-Client...
Ja, das wird bei mir nicht funktionieren. Das geht aber ganz gut.
Aber macht doch nichts. PC ist eh immer an.
... dann zum Beispiel auch ganz komfortabel
über Steam Big Picture.
Ja, und dann braucht ihr eben noch Moonlight
als Client. Und das läuft wirklich
nahezu überall. Also auf den üblichen
Desktop-Betriebssystemen sowieso,
auf Raspis, auf LG-Fernseher,
auf Chrome OS, auf der
Nintendo Switch. Es gibt sogar eine
RISC-V-Version. Ich zeige euch hier mal
vier Installationen. Hier Nummer 1
unter Windows. Es gibt einen Installer,
den kann man einfach doppelklicken oder auch eine
portable Version. Hier entpackt ihr die
ZIP-Datei in einen Ordner und startet
dann Moonlight.exe.
Dann müsst ihr Client und Host koppeln.
Das passiert, indem ihr die vierstellige
Zahl, die Moonlight euch anzeigt,
einmal in Sunshine eintippt.
Ist beides einmal gekoppelt, müsst ihr das auch
nicht wieder machen. Ja, und dann könnt ihr hier in den
Moonlight-Einstellungen einmal die
Auflösung festlegen und dann noch ein paar andere
Sachen. Hier würde ich auch allgemein...
Das ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Sparst du dir dann die Spielekonsole? Nee,
nicht wirklich. Weil du
Exklusivspiele auch nicht damit spielen kannst.
Du kannst damit nur deine PC-Spiele
halt rüber streamen.
Das läuft ja weiterhin auf deinem PC.
Es wird ja nur die Ausgabe gestreamt und der
Input.
Die Spielekonsole sparst du dir damit nicht.
Wenn du Konsolen exklusiv
Sachen spielen willst. Aber das ist
wirklich gut gemacht.
Also ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig an meine
Moonlight-Experimente erinnern, aber damals sah das
noch nicht so nice aus.
... empfehlen erstmal mit den Standardwerken
zu arbeiten. Könnt ihr alles hinterher
noch rumfummeln.
Auf Raspis ab
Raspi 4 installiert ihr Moonlight
mit diesem Befehl hier.
Steht auch unten in der Beschreibung.
Da könnt ihr Moonlight dann einfach mit
Moonlight-QT.
Am besten funktioniert das, wenn ihr parallel
keinen Desktop... Ein richtig cute
Moonlight war das.
Dafür könnt ihr zum Beispiel
Raspberry Pi oder The Light installieren.
Da ist gar kein Desktop enthalten.
Achtet nur darauf, dass ihr möglichst die aktuelle
Version nehmt, die auf
Windows 12 Bookworm basiert.
Nummer 3. Auf LG-Fernsehern
mit WebOS als Betriebssystem
ist die Installation auch
einigermaßen einfach.
Ihr müsst euch allerdings einmal zwingend
auf webostv.developer.lgi.com
einen
Developer-Account anlegen.
Und dann müsst ihr auf eurem Fernseher...
Für Shield TV wird es ja auf jeden Fall
funktionieren, hoffe ich mal.
Die findet ihr einfach im normalen
LG-Content-Store. Und dann diese App
starten, einloggen, mit dem
von euch angelegten Login
und dann auf Enable Developer Mode
drücken und auf den
Neustart des Fernsehers warten.
Dann nochmal die Developer-Mode-App starten
und Dev-Mode-Status auf
ON schalten und den
Key-Server aktivieren. Dann notiert
oder merkt oder fotografiert euch
die IP-Adresse, die euer Fernseher
anzeigt und die Passphrase.
Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Remaining Session 999 Stunden 58...
Das ist einfach die maximale Zeit,
die geht oder was? Fotografiert euch die IP-Adresse, die euer Fernseher anzeigt und die Passphrase.
Fotografiert euch die IP-Adresse, die euer Fernseher anzeigt und die Passphrase.
Ja, und dann könnt ihr an euren
Rechner gehen und das Programm
WebOS DevManager installieren.
Ach das, natürlich!
Obviously!
Bei Connection Mode auf Use Developer Mode
klicken, da dann nochmal die Checkliste
angucken, ob ihr alles gemacht habt.
Dann könnt ihr bei
Device Name eurem Fernseher einen Namen geben
und die IP-Adresse eintippen
und die Passphrase.
Ich finde aber gut, dass LG das ermöglicht.
Also,
umso mehr man machen kann
auf seinem Gerät, umso mehr Freiheit
man hat, umso besser finde ich das.
Ich finde das gut, dass
die Hersteller das ein bisschen verstecken, dass nicht jeder
Kack-Noob das einschalten kann, aber ich finde,
umso mehr du machen kannst, umso besser.
Dafür gibt's EasyClap, genau.
Das ist übrigens auch nicht illegal oder so,
es wird da nichts geroutet, sondern
das ist einfach nur der Developer Mode, das ist so vorgesehen.
Sein Gerät routen ist auch so
nicht illegal.
Wichtiger Hinweis noch,
der Developer Mode muss mindestens alle 40 Tage
einmal aufgefr...
Ach, der Kram läuft wirklich ab, ja?
... werden, ansonsten starten
über den Dev Mode installierte
Programme nicht mehr. Dafür geht ihr in die
Developer Mode App und drückt auf
Extend Session Time.
Dann geht der Timer auf 1000 Stunden hoch.
Achso, und ihr könnt nun einfach
Maus und Tastatur an den Fernseher anschließen,
der hat ja USB-Buchsen, ihr könnt aber auch
unter Einstellungen, Anschluss, Einstellungen
der Geräteverbindung einen Bluetooth-Controller
koppeln. Wenn ihr jetzt Moonlight
startet, sollte sich schon das Hauptmenü
mit dem Controller steuern lassen.
Die Maus bewegt ihr übrigens, wenn ihr nur
einen Controller angeschlossen habt, mit gleichzeitig
gedrückter Mitteltaste, also zum Beispiel
die PlayStation-Taste und Analogstick
rechts. Installation Nummer 4,
auf dem Steam Deck installiert
ihr Moonshine im Desktop-Modus
einfach über Discount.
Danke schön für den Sub, 7LQS.
... dass ihr dann halt Moonshine
auch im normalen Steam Deck Menü seht.
Du wirst keine App dafür bauen können,
weil Apps keinen Zugriff darauf haben.
Ich habe eine alte externe Festplatte,
die wird nicht mehr vom Rechner erkannt
und klackt dabei.
Hat jemand einen Tipp, wie ich die Festplatte
komplett zerstören kann, wenn ich alles
aufschraube, einzeln?
Also, ein grundsätzlicher Tipp ist,
immer Vollverschlüsselung nutzen,
dann hast du prinzipiell keine Probleme
und kannst sie einfach wegschmeißen.
So, aber hast du jetzt ja nicht gemacht.
Aber das ist so prinzipiell eines der Gründe,
warum ich auf allen meinen Laufwerken
Vollverschlüsselung benutze,
wegen genau sowas.
Das zweite ist Festplatten zerstören.
Du kannst es so machen wie Google.
Da brauchst du aber so eine hydraulische Presse für.
Das wirst du nicht haben.
Ansonsten würde ich ehrlich gesagt
einfach ein bisschen mit dem Hammer
drauf rumhauen.
Oder durchbohren.
Ich würde aber ein bisschen
mit dem Hammer drauf rumhauen.
Ganz im Ernst,
eine Festplatte ist relativ fragil
gegen Schläge.
Und wenn es nachher wieder so ist,
wie eine alte Magnetfestplatte ist,
immer da einfach ein paarmal drauf ordentlich
mit richtig Schmackes mit dem Hammer,
dann ist das Ding kaputt.
Kann man die Vollverschlüsselung nicht
nachträglich machen?
Ja nicht, wenn die Festplatte nicht mehr funktioniert.
Du kannst sie nachträglich machen,
solange das Gerät noch funktioniert.
Aber das Gerät funktioniert ja nicht mehr.
Du kannst durchbohren,
du kannst aber einfach drauf kloppen.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du auch aus dem Fenster schmeißen
oder so aus dem zweiten Stock.
Ein paarmal.
Und dann kannst du den Hammer draufhauen.
Ordentlich, ordentlich Schmackes.
Reicht da BitLocker?
Wenn du dem Hersteller von BitLocker
vertraust, ja.
... und Moonlight unterstützen übrigens prinzipiell
HDR, aber das geht nur, wenn das
physisch an den Hostrechner angeschlossenen
Display auch HDR kann.
Bei mir ist das so, dass man normalerweise
im Arbeitszimmer kein HDR beherrscht.
Aber der OLED-Fan...
Kann meine HDR?
BenQ 2?
Fuck, habe ich den nicht eben gerade
irgendwo gesucht? BenQ?
Ja, der da.
Kann der HDR?
Übersicht, nice.
Ist gut, dass die BenQ-Seite so gut funktioniert.
Kann der HDR?
Nein, ne.
Brat.
Ah, das ist die Display-Test-Seite.
HDR.
Wo ist denn
der Datenblatt?
HDR.
Kein HDR. No!
Set.
... im Wohnzimmer schon.
Um hier jetzt HDR aktivieren zu können...
Das kann man bestimmt faken unter Windows.
... bräuchte ich halt entweder
einen HDR-fähigen Arbeitsplatzmonitor
oder so einen sogenannten Edit-Emulator.
Ja, genau.
Also ein kleines Kästchen, was dem Rechner
einen beliebigen Monitor vorrauchelt.
Ich habe so einen für 6,99 ausprobiert
und das klappt tatsächlich. Nice.
Was noch wichtig ist, eigentlich ist das Ganze
alles nur zum Streamen im eigenen Heimnetz,
aber ihr könnt euren PC über Sunshine
auch nach außen streambar machen.
Also dass ihr zum Beispiel im Urlaub
oder so per Tablet auf eurem PC zockt.
Dafür könnt ihr das im Moonlight...
Eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder?
Nimmst dein
Notebook oder so mit,
VPN nach Hause
und
let's go.
Ist ja die Frage, wie gut das Hotel-WLAN ist.
... StingTool installieren. Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Mein Fazit.
Also im 2003 Team fanden alle...
Du brauchst dann aber jemand,
der daheim dann Rechner rebooten kann,
gell, wenn was ist.
... im Vorschlag mit dem PC-Game-Streaming
ziemlich speziell.
So nach dem Motto,
machen das echt Leute?
Aber ich kenne echt eine ganze Menge Menschen,
die irgendwo einen Desktop-PC stehen haben,
damit gerne spielen würden.
Man muss ja nicht spielen damit,
man kann ja auch einfach den Desktop dahin streamen,
wo einfach ein Display steht
oder ein Fernseher, also irgendwo, wo nicht der Display steht.
Und rumtragen
von so einem fetten Desktop-PC
ist ja auch keine gute Option.
Also ich kann euch versichern,
dass ich das Ganze weiterhin regelmäßig nutzen werde.
Ich hab nämlich zum Beispiel GTA 5
nach Jahrzehnten immer noch nicht durchgespielt,
hab aber einen alten PC gespielt...
Ich auch nicht.
... und will das jetzt gerne auf dem Sofa zu Ende spielen.
Und ich bin echt sehr pingelig,
was die Bildqualität angeht.
Also wenn das jetzt schlechter aussehen würde
als direkt am PC, dann würde ich das nicht machen.
Ich denke, dass Sony mit dem Portal
sogar eine eigene Handheld-Konsole
rausgebracht hat, die nur dafür da ist,
die Bild- und Tonausgabe einer PS5
zu streamen.
Also vielleicht ist das Ganze doch ein Thema,
was viele Leute interessiert.
Kleine Bonus-Info, mit dem Tool Chiaki
könnt ihr die PS5 sehr komfortabel
auf Steam Deck streamen.
Ja, jedenfalls, wie seht ihr das ganze Streaming-Thema?
Findet ihr das interessant,
oder ist das für euch Fricke-Kram,
den niemand braucht?
Und wenn ich Anwendungszweck dafür hätte,
würde ich es auch nochmal ausprobieren.
Oh, Maurice hat ein neues Diablo 4 Video.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
Diablo 4 juckt mich eigentlich gar nicht mal großartig.
Bzw. hat mich nie groß gejuckt.
Ich hab's ja gar nicht
... nicht mal gekauft, ja.
Nach den letzten
Blizzard-Enttäuschungen.
Natürlich muss es faster sein,
weil es in Rust written ist.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
The Day Before,
die Geschichte einer Spielekatastrophe,
die jeder kommen sah.
Ich sah die Spielekatastrophe
von The Day Before nicht kommen.
Und wisst ihr auch warum nicht?
Weil mich das Spiel so null
interessiert hat von Anfang an.
Null. Gar nicht.
Ich hab nie den Hype um das Spiel verstanden.
Kann mich schlüssig irgendjemand
den Hype um dieses Spiel erklären?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Ich hab das mitbekommen,
dass da alle gehypt drauf sind.
Hab festgestellt, okay, es ist
ein Multiplayer-Zombie-Survival-Game.
Als gäbe es nicht schon 5 Milliarden
Multiplayer-Zombie-Survival-Games.
Ich hab's nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Es war mir komplett unbegreiflich.
Gutes Marketing hatten sie vielleicht
so ein bisschen danach, ja.
Aber so der initiale Hype muss ja auch erstmal
und das Interesse muss ja auch erstmal da sein.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Warum haben wir das erklärt?
Ah ja, übrigens.
Das Game wurde ja eingestellt mittlerweile.
Wonka S.
Musik, Alter.
Ich auch nicht.
Geht's dir genauso wie mir?
Ich hab bis heute keine Ahnung,
was der Unterschied ist.
Okay, doch, ich weiß, was der Unterschied ist.
Days Gone ist
ein Singleplayer.
Also, ja,
Action-Dings, Playstation,
ursprünglich Playstation exclusive.
Spiel mit
Zombie-Endzeit-Thematik.
Dates ist ein
Arma-Mod.
Und dann gab es
noch Warts. Gab es doch zwischenzeitlich
auch noch, oder?
Gibt es das überhaupt noch, Warts?
Das heißt, zwischenzeitlich wurde das
umbenannt. Ach, jetzt
heißt es wieder Warts.
Hieß es nicht die ganze Zeit?
Das ist wieder was anderes.
A1Z1
gab es noch. Es gab noch
Survivor Stories oder sowas.
Infestation.
Genau.
Survivor Stories gab es da noch.
2020.
Da gab es so
viel und ich fand alles
mega lahmarschig und
langweilig. Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Back 4 Blood
sind die ehemaligen Left 4 Dead-Leute.
Das ist quasi nur Left 4 Dead in schlechter.
Hast du dir schon die neuen
Sideloading-Richtlinien angesehen? Nee.
Was gibt's denn da Neues? Muss man den
Kram jetzt nicht irgendwie
laufen? Neues Sideloaden?
Okay, lass uns mal gucken.
Und aus die Maus.
The Day Before ist seit dem 22.
Januar 2024 offiziell
eingestellt. Publisher MyTona
hat alle Server des Vermeidens
Ich muss ja auch dazu sagen, ich hab von MyTona noch nie
was gehört.
Und von Dings hier, von
Pantastic
auch nicht.
Ich lecke Critical Information.
Wieso ist das mittlerweile wieder da, oder wie?
Browser Engines
außer Webkit sind
jetzt erlaubt. Heißt das
wirklich,
wir sehen jetzt einen echten
Chrome unter
iOS? Ja, aber
Moment, Moment.
Da ist doch garantiert wieder irgendwelche
Beschränkungen drinne. So nach dem Motto
Chrome Browser
Engine oder Chrome darf
keine PWA's auf
den Startbildschirm installieren
und sowas. Da gibt's doch
garantiert irgendwelche. Das lese ich mir
jetzt nicht alles durch. Da gibt's doch
100 pro wieder irgendwas.
Bevor sie zu YouTube weitergeht, ich lehne einfach
alles ab. Okay, dann gucken wir das
mal. Wo ist der hier?
Was ist
der Teil davon, den ich mir angucken muss?
Das Intro, oder?
Ach hier, iOS Changes.
Was werden die Klienten mit den EU's Digital Markets
Act Regeln aussehen, und
die Antwort ist...Malicious.
Ich dachte, es wäre lecker,
aber wir...klar.
Ich meine, es klingt gut zu Beginn. Apple hat
bemerkt, dass iOS Drittpartien App-Store
unterstützen wird. Sie nennen sie
Marketplaces, sowie Drittpartien
Payment-Systeme und Browser
Engines außer Webkit, damit
man tatsächlich einen Browser benutzen kann, der
nicht nur Safari mit Chrome
Spraypaint ist. Aber dann erkennt man,
dass diese leckeren Geschenke nur
zur EU kommen, weil sie
wirklich sehr gefährlich sind.
Also sprich, im Endeffekt
macht Apple
das Mindeste, um die EU zufriedenzustellen
und nicht generell.
Was im Endeffekt heißt,
dass es ziemlich kacke sein wird,
wenn du ein App-Anbieter bist und deine App
international vermarkten möchtest.
Ja, deine App
quasi das nutzen zu lassen,
weil du es ja nur für Länder in der EU...
Das ist ja schon wieder echt richtig hängen geblieben, oder?
Und ja,
du bist nicht sicher, ob du sie überhaupt noch
mehr willst, weil du denkst, dass du Apple
vor dem Handeln von ihnen spittest.
Alternative-App-Marketplaces müssen
von Apple verantwortlich sein.
Und alle Apps, die sie hosten, müssen
notarisiert werden.
Eine perfekte Dystopie.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist jetzt ja auch nicht so,
dass jetzt, dass jegliche anderen
App-Stores direkt gleich wieder
unsinnig machen.
Apple-ism for reviewed by bots and humans.
Prepare to be notarized.
While many are repeating claims
that iOS will support
sideloading,
installing standalone App-Packages
outside of any App-Store.
Ja, das soll mir recht sein,
dass man den Kram nicht alle Woche oder so neu installieren muss.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Da kann ich vielleicht irgendwann auch mal
eine iOS-App bauen, um mir das mal
einfach so just for fun anzugucken,
ohne dass ich einen Apple-Account brauche,
Geld bezahlen muss dafür und ein
App-Store, wie man das auf Android,
Windows, Linux und MacOS
machen kann. Das wird das nicht unterstützen.
Und es wird nur wilder.
Um Entwickler, die ihre Apps
auf Alternativ-App-Marktplätzen distribuieren
oder sogar dritte-Parte-Payment-Prozesse
nutzen zu können, müssen sie die
neuen Business-Termine akzeptieren.
Das ist die neue Business-Termine.
Geh' dir an.
Der Kerl regt mich auf, ja.
Das betrifft einen niedrigeren 10%-Kreis
der App-Store-Rentgen
oder 17% für digitale Geräte
plus ein extra 3%
um Apple's own Payment-System zu nutzen,
welches auch von
extra 3%...
Musst du jetzt bezahlen, wenn du sideloadest?
Nee, oder? Moment.
Die bezahlen jetzt weniger?
Für Apps in der EU?
Was ist das?
...to use Apple's own
Payment-System, which will also
spare users from the pop-up
warning them that they may be about to hand over
their savings to a Nigerian prince.
If they don't use the right one.
But the new terms also include
Apple's own version of Unity's
scandalous per-install-fee
from last year.
Once an app hits 1 million installs,
its devs will have to pay a
Core Technology Fee
or CTF of
50 Euro-Cents
for every new user who installs it
annually.
Moment, die haben die App schon
gekauft
und die installieren sie dann nochmal
und dann musst du Geld bezahlen?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment, das heißt,
du hast eine App,
also das heißt im Endeffekt,
du bringst eine App raus
für
2 Euro.
Jemand kauft die
und die App ist super beliebt
und ganz viele Leute downloaden das
und irgendwann kauft er sich
ein neues iPhone, lädt sich das neu runter,
dann musst du 50 Cent
bezahlen, wenn er die zum ersten Mal
Das heißt im Endeffekt, da darf sich die
App nicht verlassen.
Das heißt, die App ist super beliebt
und dann musst du 20 Jahre lang installieren
die App und du hast kein Geld damit verdient
oder wie.
Und wie ist das mit kostenlosen Apps?
Kostenlose, sehr beliebte Apps?
Kosten die jetzt Geld oder was?
Ich weiß, der Entwickler,
das meine ich doch,
wenn du der Entwickler wärst.
Angenommen, du entwickelst eine kostenlose App,
die super beliebt ist,
keine Ahnung, irgendeine QR-Code-Scan-App
und dann musst du Geld bezahlen
für eine kostenlose App.
Das ist der Unity-Engine-Move.
Ja, schon.
Vielleicht sollte ich mir noch ein paar Apple-Aktien kaufen.
Wenn es mehr Stones gibt.
Ja, dann lohnt es sich aber überhaupt nicht
über extra App-Stores
das Ganze
runterzuladen.
Ich sehe schon,
es gibt noch längere Rechtsstreitigkeiten
da mit Apple.
Ja klar, natürlich.
Aber die Frage ist,
wie viele Dollar für die
fraudulösen Transaktionen
2022 sind.
Das gleiche,
was Google im selben Jahr blockiert hat
auf der viel weniger restriktiven Play-Store.
Aber es gibt viel mehr Android-Apps
in der Welt und sie sind viel schwieriger
für Babys zu nutzen.
Das Argument ist verrächtlich.
Aber Apple hat auch...
...eine Sache veröffentlicht,
die einfach nur gute Nachrichten ist.
Xbox Cloud Gaming kann jetzt
eine Einzel-IOS-App anbieten
mit der Fähigkeit, ihre gesamte
Liste von Spielen zu streamen.
Das ist, wie es schon
auf anderen Systemen funktioniert,
aber nicht auf dem minimalistischen
Fischer-Preis von Phones.
In dem Fall ist es
eher die eigene Software,
die Papierspiele hat man
in der Schicht und die
kann man einfach
mit der Software
ausprobieren.
Ist es in der Fuck- выд,
und wie auch immer.
Da hätten wir
teilweise die folgende Frage
noch.
Was heißt ewig
und wie wie
war 2001 oder so
oder 2021, 2001
gab's noch nicht. Hast du schon
deinen neuen Traumjob gesehen?
Ne? Remote Windows
3.11 Administrator, das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
Das ist doch ein Joke.
Und am Ende kommt dann
Ach,
G-Bated.
Wir suchen noch jemand anderes.
Ich save mir das mal, falls was braucht.
Remote Windows
3.11 Administrator.
Wenn ich weiß,
Deutsch.
Das sind doch irgendwelche Personalvermittler, oder?
Das Ergebnis ihrer Arbeit
ist eine hochwertige
Displaysoftware, deren
Schnittstellen zur Fahrzeugsteuerung
Ach, uraltes Legacy-Zeug.
Deren Schnittstellen
zur Fahrzeugsteuerung bzw. Fahrzeugleittechnik
reibungslos funktionieren auf den
Führerstand-Display-Systemen der
Hochgeschwindigkeits- und Regionalzüge,
während dem Fahrer die wichtigste Technik
Windows 3.11
Noah Laws Pancakes, sage ich für den Sub.
So wirklich Sinn ergibt es jetzt aber immer noch nicht.
Projektbeschreibung, Treiberaktualisierung,
Pflege des Altsystems.
Wie sieht eine Pflege
von Windows 3.11 aus?
Dafür gibt es doch nichts Neues mehr.
Skills.
Kenntnisse in Windows 3.11.
Ich kenne Windows 3.11, das war es dann aber auch.
Kenntnisse zu Legacy-Betriebssystemen
und zu Windows-Managern.
Zu Windows-Managern?
Insbesondere MS-DOS
und Windows-Verweigerung.
Was sind die Werte, die wir hier haben?
Was sind zu Windows-Managern?
Was soll das sein?
Window-Manager im Linux-Kontext kenne ich.
Gerne auch ZBAS-Kenntnisse.
Was ist ZBAS?
Das Fahr...
Ah, was von der Bahn?
Moment, die Monitore bei der Bahn
in den Zügen laufen noch mit Windows 3.11?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ist das so?
Kenntnisse mit bildgebenden Systemen
oder im Bahnbereich sind von Vorteil.
Kenntnisse zu Legacy-Betriebssystemen
und zu...
Das hatten wir doch schon da oben schon mal.
Das bieten wir.
Zahlungszielverkürzung.
Attraktive Möglichkeiten
zur Verkürzung ihres persönlichen
Zahlungsziels.
Was soll mir das sagen?
Dass ich mein Gehalt schon am 15.
anstatt am 20. kriege oder was?
Hä?
Was ist das? Hä?
Mir ist das doch scheißegal,
ob die am 15. oder am 20. bezahlen.
Die sollen regelmäßig einmal im Monat.
Die können auch dreimal im Monat überweisen.
Das ist mir auch wurscht.
Den Vorteil hier...
Mir ist das vollkommen egal,
wann die das überweisen.
Es sei denn, die überweisen das einmal im Monat.
Einfaches Gutschriftenverfahren.
Kein Zeitraumrechnungserstellen mehr nötig.
Hä?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Was soll mir das überhaupt sagen?
Einfaches Gutschriftenverfahren.
Keine Zeitraumrechnungserstellung mehr nötig.
Was soll mir das sagen?
Ich soll mich um Windows 3.11 kümmern.
Die meinen, dass ich...
Stellen die mich quasi als freier Mitarbeiter an.
Ach so!
Ja dann ergibt das auch Sinn.
Die stellen einen quasi als freien Mitarbeiter...
Ach ja.
Dann, dann...
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich das auch.
Okay.
Das ist eine Stelle für Freelancer.
Ja dann ergibt das Sinn.
So nach dem Motto, du bekommst dein Geld einfach früher.
Ja dann...
Jetzt ergibt das insgesamt mehr Sinn.
Ja.
Ich bin ein Freelancer.
Aber man das unter dem Gesichtspunkt sieht.
Abrechnung ohne Umwege.
Schnell und zufällig Honorar-zahlung.
Und digitalisierter Unterschriftprozess Difficult.
Richtig geile Vorteile oder massive...
Tja...
Auf Gulp können sie vertrauen...
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Wollen wir mal gucken ob das stimmt?
Kununu?
Gulp!
Naja!
Naaaaja!
Moment sind die das überhaupt?
Sind das überhaupt...
Das ist der falsche Laden.
Das ist das Richtige.
Ja, ist schon...
Ganz ehrlich, Gulb-Bewertungen...
Konono-Bewertungen sind in der Regel
eh nicht sonderlich gut.
Das ist, glaube ich, schon in Ordnung.
Mehr Schein als ein...
Ja gut, das ist bei den ganzen Vermittlungsläden so.
Heißt das im Endeffekt,
die suchen eigentlich jemanden für die Bahn?
Du wirst freier Mitarbeiter bei Gulb
und Gulb vermittelt dich dann an die Bahn.
Und kriegen dafür Fettstonks.
Die könnten ja auch die Bahn direkt einstellen.
Und dann könnten die sich
die ganze Profession sparen.
Naja, gut.
Sehr, sehr Legacy-lastig.
Aber was ist das für eine...
Feines-Jobs.online
Klingt ja schon mal ganz toll.
Es gibt...
Feines-Jobs.box
wäre jetzt angesagt. Was ist das hier?
Snoggard.
Wer? Wer ist Snoggard?
Klingt irgendwie nach...
Nach was Schwedischem.
Okay.
Moderner und sicherer Arbeitsplatz.
Du erhältst...
Ja, was suchen die denn überhaupt?
Äh.
Moment.
Was suchen die denn?
Es ist ja schön, dass ich was erhalte, aber...
So, jetzt bewerben.
Ah, hier.
Filialmitarbeiter.
Alles klar.
Das sieht eher nach einer Comedy-Gruppeseite aus, oder?
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was die eigentlich suchen anhand dieser Webseite.
Ja, Filialmitarbeiter steht in der Adressleiste.
Ja, mal seriously.
Also, es kann jetzt ja nett sein,
dass die Beschreibung der Stelle
in der Adressleiste versteckt ist, oder?
Da müsste doch schon was stehen,
was die eigentlich suchen.
Nee, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn für mich gerade.
Das ist der Noob-Filter wahrscheinlich.
Lies den Firmentitel mal rückwärts.
Dra...
Dragons.
Ha!
Okay, das finde ich cool.
Das finde ich nice.
Snoggard-Dragons. Das finde ich nice.
Trotzdem verstehe ich nicht,
was die eigentlich suchen.
Interessant.
Wen sucht ihr denn genau?
Okay, also was...
Moderner und sicherer Arbeitsplatz.
Erhalte ein cooles Umfeld mit modernster Technologie.
Hier kannst du nicht nur produktiv arbeiten,
sondern auch spannende Aufgaben übernehmen.
Okay, solange ich kein Windows-PC benutzen muss.
Preisnachlässe auf unser Angebot.
Leistungsorientierte Vergütung.
Du erhältst ein Festgehalt von bis zu...
Das ist ja fast unter Mindestlohn, oder?
Ja.
Sowie zusätzliche monatliche Prämien
und Vergütungen.
Und Provisionen.
Bis zu 30.000 Euro.
Nice.
Pro Monat.
Dann lasse ich mit mir reden, wenn das pro Monat ist.
Begeisterte Arbeit.
Verwirkliche deine Leidenschaft.
Zusätzliche Benefits.
Okay, interessant.
Wen sucht ihr denn genau?
Filialmitarbeiter.
Nicht wirklich.
Telesales.
Oh Gott, hör mir bloß auf, Alter.
PC-Techniker.
Pro Monat baue ich da auch PCs zusammen.
Kein Ding.
Bin ich dabei.
Die musst du dann bezahlen.
Du musst dann 50 Cent
für jede angefangene Minute bezahlen
an deinen Arbeitgeber, dass du dort arbeiten darfst.
Das ist ja die Apple-Logik.
Ja, ja, sehe ich auch so.
Würde ich auch bauen.
Baue ich die ganze Nacht PCs.
Wobei, wenn ich PCs baue, kriegen die Mainboards immer Mikro-Risse.
Wisst ihr ja.
Habt ihr ja gesehen.
Eigentlich wollte ich das Video über den GitHub...
Äh, GitLab.
Exploit gucken.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Gucken, ob das was taugt.
Oh, das klingt ja super langweilig, Alter.
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist mir zu...
Das ist ein...
Das klingt nach einschlafen, das Video.
Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
GitLab-Exploits sind langweilig mittlerweile.
Und du meinst, weil es nicht so oft welche gibt?
Kole...
Jetzt würde ich hier Wirecard lesen.
Kollege auf der Arbeit hat gesagt, er hat noch Wirecard-Aktien.
Die Behälter auch.
Aus historischen Gründen.
Was ist das denn?
Karriere starten als Ingenieur bei Südzucker.
So viel hat er noch nie verdient.
Ja gut, wenn das sein erster Job ist.
Ist klar, dass er noch nie so viel verdient hat, oder?
Zählst du von Tarkov?
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige auf der Welt, der das noch nie gespielt hat.
Hast du Aktien?
Ja, hab ich.
Guter Hinweis.
Ich muss mal kurz reingucken.
Stonks.
Was machen die Stonks?
Scalable.
Die Stonks sagen...
Wow.
Alter.
Ho.
Die Stonks gingen ab?
Boah, ey.
Die Stonks gingen ja richtig ab.
Plus tausend...
Plus tausend und ein Euro.
In der Woche.
Merci vielmals.
Merci, Stonks, Alter.
Okay, ich mein, davon hab ich nix.
Davon hab ich erst was, wenn ich's verkaufen würde.
Alter, Big Stonks.
Gingen ja richtig ab.
Pog.
Was macht der Bit...
Bitcoin-Kurs?
Der ist letztens schon hochgegangen, hab ich schon gesehen.
Wow.
Ja, Bitcoin, genau, wenn ich das ganz gut hab.
Ich hab nur nen ETF.
Langweiligste, was es gibt, hab ich als ETF.
So, dann gucken wir uns doch das hier mal an.
Wir kriegen zum ersten Mal hier Einblick in dieses Ingenieurwesen.
Der Drive, den ich hab, der ist bestimmt auch,
weil ich von Haupt-, Mittelschule zu Abitur
und dann zu Bachelor, zu Master alles mitgemacht hab.
Ich hab noch keinen Plan, was ich mit so viel Geld mache.
Am besten nicht alles sinnlos ausgeben.
Sonst Not Stonks.
Hallo.
Ich bin Sui, 32 Jahre alt.
Ich bin Training bei der Südzucker.
Ihr werdet also sehen, wie man hier zum Ingenieur wird.
Also ich fahr immer mit dem Board mit der Arbeit.
Während meiner Masterarbeit begonnen.
Da konnte ich mir noch kein Fahrrad leisten.
Und jetzt erst mal auf die Fresse fliegen.
Weil Hände in der Tasche und dann nicht abfangen können.
Ich seh teilweise Leute mit dem Fahrrad fahren im Winter,
wenn's kalt ist und die haben die Hände einstecken.
Also,
das wär mir nix.
Ich mein, ich könnte, ich kann nicht freihändig Fahrrad fahren.
Ich hab teilweise schon Probleme,
wenn ich normal auf dem Fahrrad sitze und mich umdrehen muss,
weit, dass ich, dass ich rumwackel.
Also,
wie geht das dem Rose-Fahrrad?
Ja, Totalschaden.
Und in meiner Größe ist grad nix lieferbar.
Momentan ist hier in der Zuckerfabrik viel los.
Da ist, äh,
Rüben kampagniert.
Das heißt, die Rüben werden jetzt geerntet.
Die werden jetzt aus dem Boden gezogen.
Und, äh,
kleingackt und verarbeitet.
Der Ort hier, den, da gucken wir uns dann später den, den Zucker an.
Da war ich selbst noch nicht.
Das ist dann der Expeditions-Spot für heute.
Der Trainee-Technik bei Südzucker geht insgesamt 18 Monate.
Und alle vier Monate wechseln wir den Standort.
Der Schwerpunkt der Aufgabe liegt schon im großen Bereich,
im Ingenieursbereich, im Management-Bereich.
Management.
Öh.
Offiziell arbeite ich, glaub ich, 7,4 Stunden pro Tag.
Aber die Arbeit macht mir jetzt ziemlich viel Spaß.
Also ich muss mich bemühen, dass ich nicht, äh,
über die 10 Stunden komme.
Hallo.
Wie geht's denn gang?
Richtiger, richtiger High-Performer.
Wo alle Ingenieure ihre Büros haben.
Ich hätte sozusagen...
Das ist mein Büro.
Ich hab zwei Aufgaben hier im Zuckerwerk.
Einmal geht's darum, dass ich während der Rüben-Kampagne
die Zuckerfabrik kennenlerne und erkunde.
Dann hab ich noch eine zweite Aufgabe.
Und da geht's um diesen Reinigungsapparat,
den ich planen muss, den ich entwerfen muss.
Damit reinigen sie verschiedene andere Geräte,
die ich hier während der Produktion machen muss,
den ich entwerfen muss.
Damit...
Sind das Handschuhe?
Oder sind das Rührer?
Aufschneidmesser.
PDF.
Handschuhe.
Ah, das wird dann hinzugepackt.
Da kann man da so reingreifen.
Reinigen Sie die Zuckerfabrik.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja.
Reinigen Sie verschiedene andere Geräte,
die hier während der Produktion schmutzig werden.
Die haben jetzt ein Gerät,
aber das ist schon ziemlich alt
und vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so sicher
von einer anderen Zeit sozusagen.
Und ich versuche, das Ding eben neu zu machen.
Ich bin aufgeregt.
Heute sind ein paar wichtige Meetings für das Projekt.
Ich muss sagen, er versprüht enorm viel positive Energie,
wenn man das mal so ausdrücken kann.
Sehr viel gesehen.
Da habe ich noch richtig viel geguckt.
Ich habe mir gestern zum Beispiel die Abwasseranlage angeguckt.
Das ist so typisch das,
was man bei der Umweltverfahrenstechnik lernt.
Da geradeaus.
Und dort wird der Zucker gelagert.
Und den schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Ah, das ist ein Killer.
Hallo.
Mein Name ist Sü.
Ich bin der neue Trainer in die Technik.
Kann man das angucken?
Boah, das ist eine Menge Zucker hier.
Ja, wenn wir hier die Hallen...
Oh mein...
Nö.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
Jetzt sind sie noch relativ leer.
Wenn wir diese Hallen zusammen machen,
dann haben wir noch viel Zucker.
Oh mein...
Nö.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
Jetzt sind sie noch relativ leer.
Wenn wir diese Hallen komplett füllen,
stehen wir ungefähr 4500 Tonnen.
Ich habe ja ziemlich niedrig begonnen in der Mittelschule.
Da hat es schon viel Arbeit gebraucht,
um da rauszukommen,
weil meine Eltern sind mit Migrationshintergrund
nicht dazu fähig,
mir bildungstechnisch so viel zu programmen,
weil meine Eltern...
Was Bachelor?
Bachelor Biotechnologie?
Master Biomasse-Technologie?
Ich wusste noch nicht mal,
dass Biomasse-Technologie...
Das ist das...
Das Wort überhaupt.
Dann sind wir mit Migrationshintergrund
nicht dazu fähig,
mir bildungstechnisch...
Was ist Mittelschule?
Ja, Realschule.
...so viel Support zu geben,
dass ich gut durch diese Zeit gekommen bin.
Also musste alles von alleine passieren.
Ist es nicht Hauptschule?
Ist es nicht Realschule?
...bin ich jetzt sozusagen hier,
um meiner jüngeren Verwandtschaft zu zeigen,
okay, das kann man auch machen.
Danke dir für deine Zeit, Tobi.
Ja.
Am Ende konnte er mir noch mit dem Ausbauprojekt
ein paar Informationen geben.
Also Ausbauprojekt ist ja diese Maschine,
die ich da baue.
Okay, dann ist es anscheinend Hauptschule.
Das Herausforderndste ist,
dass per Studium einen gar nicht auf...
Aber da sieht man es ja wieder,
Schule hat da wenig zu sagen.
...diese Arbeit vorbereitet
und man hier sozusagen
rein aus Eigeninitiative schauen muss,
okay, wo kriege ich die Informationen her?
Wer kann mir da helfen?
Und da muss man sich schon manchmal überwinden,
Leute anzusprechen.
Herr Kuli, haben Sie gerade...
Spricht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
für die Struktur, oder?
Ja.
Wenn du keine Ahnung hast,
wo du irgendwo Infos herbekommst.
Ein paar Zeit.
Jetzt den Auskochkasten so gut wie fertig geplant.
Ich weiß, wie groß die Pumpe aussehen soll.
Ich weiß, wie groß das Gerät aussehen soll,
wo die Rohrleitungen entlaufen sind.
Und jetzt...
Alter!
Da würde ich ja Angst kriegen bei dem Augenkontakt.
Guck mal, der klotzt den die ganze Zeit an,
als ist er stinkig mit ihm.
Guck euch das mal an.
Jetzt den Auskochkasten...
Der guckt den sich die ganze Zeit an, so...
...starren, starren, starren.
Ich weiß nicht, wie groß die Pumpe aussehen soll.
Alter, da würde ich ja nervös werden bei...
Wo das Gerät aussehen soll,
wo die Rohrleitungen entlaufen sind.
Und jetzt geht es mir darum,
wie sieht der Boden aus?
Was für ein Gehäuse mache ich drumrum?
Was für ein Dach habe ich?
Habe ich eine Lüftung?
Und all die Sachen.
Die gleiche Idee von Herrn Freitag ist,
ob diese Chemikalie nur im Container bleibt
und nicht überall hier und da.
Er hat mir wieder Tipps gegeben.
Vielleicht ist er auch einfach zu motiviert.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich echt,
für manche Leute ein Problem, ja.
Wenn die nämlich überhaupt keinen Bock haben
und super motivierte Leute zu ihnen kommen,
dann müssen die nämlich auch was machen.
Es gibt schon eine Anlage,
die so ähnlich abläuft.
Er versprüht aber auch enorm viel Motivations...
Ja, Energie so.
Und die würde ich...
Ich weiß, wer sie jetzt designt hat.
Gucke ich mir die Anlage einfach so an.
Ich weiß, wo sie rumsteht.
Die Hoffnung ist,
dass ich dann genau das gleiche Ding einfach...
Das ist so jemand,
könnte ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Du willst abends heimgehen
und er kommt dann in die Ecke.
Ah, hast du auch mal kurz fünf Minuten Zeit?
Mich würde interessieren,
was die zweite Schraube von unten links genau macht.
Aber ist doch nice.
Ich finde es gut, wenn Leute motiviert sind.
Nur sein Teil einfach abkopieren kann
und dann mein Innenleben sozusagen reinhauen kann.
Ich habe genug unmotivierte Leute gesehen.
Und ich bin auch nicht immer der Motivierteste, ja.
Auch noch dazu.
Lüftung, Pumpe.
So, meine Reaktion, als ich das gesehen habe.
Das, genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht,
als ich da reingeguckt habe.
Hier, sauber, saubere Arbeit.
Ich habe nichts erkannt,
aber scheint alles wirklich ordentlich zu sein.
Lüftung, Pumpe, Licht.
Hätte ich auch so gemacht.
Der Boden hat überall solche Auffangwände.
Das brauche ich auch dann später.
Oder man hätte auch sagen können,
gibt es das Video noch?
Nein, das meine ich gar nicht.
Nice.
Die ganze Arbeit, die ich hier mache,
ist die Vorarbeit für einen Ingenieur.
Das geht an meinen Tutor.
Ich erstelle sozusagen einen Einkaufswarenkorb
mit allen möglichen technischen Spezifikationen
und Angeboten, die ich von den Unternehmen habe.
Der ist echt richtig krass motiviert.
Genauso wie die eine von Amazon,
die wir uns letztens angeguckt haben.
Die war auch komplett gehypt da drauf.
So dass er, wenn ich dann hier weg bin
und in der nächsten Station bin,
dann kann er einfach die Datei öffnen,
schauen, was ich gemacht habe
und dann gleich daraufhin weiterarbeiten.
Realistisch betrachtet bleiben solche Projekte
einfach genau in dem Status für immer.
Also wenn er weg ist,
wird das einfach liegen bleiben
und niemanden mehr interessieren.
Das habe ich oft genug erlebt bei so Übungsprojekten.
Eigentlich, das wird immer gesagt so,
oh ja, das ist schon wichtig
und im Prinzip will es keiner haben.
... da überhaupt die Trainingstelle genommen zu haben,
weil ich habe mich entgegen von Promotionsstellen entschieden.
Also das habe ich tatsächlich
beim alten Arbeitgeber öfters erlebt.
Da hatten wir auch so einen,
also nicht Ausbildungsprogramm,
sondern so ein,
ich kann euch den Namen jetzt nicht sagen,
sonst könnt ihr nach Google,
konnte man sich bewerben dafür,
wenn du fertig studiert hast.
So ein Ausbildungsprogramm,
also nicht für IHK-Azubis,
sondern so was, wie er macht.
Da gab es auch ganz viele Projekte,
so nach dem Motto,
oh cool, bräuchten wir
und das haben die sich dann angeguckt.
Und mir ist,
also mir fällt jetzt spontan nicht ein Projekt ein von,
was da hinterlassen wurde,
was dann irgendwie weiterverfolgt wurde.
Und da bereue ich es jetzt immer noch nicht.
Quality is Destiny.
Oh nein, hör mir auf.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Jetzt hast du mich daran erinnert.
Quality is Destiny.
Auch eine große Portion
Jägerschnitzel nehmen, bitte.
Ich auch.
Würde ich auch.
Große Portion Jägerschnitzel
wünsche ich jetzt auch.
Wobei, gleich ist Spaghetti angesagt.
Mein Vater als auch meine Mutter
sind beide von jeher selbstständig gewesen.
Jeder hatte einen
ein eigenes Restaurant.
Von Kind auf musste dann natürlich immer
im Restaurant ausgeholfen werden.
Das war auch kein Problem für mich.
Die haben mich jetzt auch durch das gesamte Studium
besser als Hartz IV chillen.
Du bist
oder
man nennt es ja nicht mal Hartz IV.
Es ist jetzt ja Bürgergeld.
den gesamten Studium alles sozusagen finanziert.
Jetzt nicht, dass ich ein good life hatte,
aber genügend, dass ich überleben konnte sozusagen.
Und jetzt ist es soweit.
Jetzt habe ich endlich mal den ersten Job.
Der erste Lohn kam auch schon rein.
Jetzt soweit,
dass ich auch was zurückgeben kann.
Jetzt mache ich auch ein bisschen Büroarbeit.
Ich glaube, das macht er auch.
Der macht einen so einen
pflichtbewussten Eindruck.
Um zu gucken, wie viele Rohstoffe brauche ich
und wie viele Reinigungs-Chemikalien brauche ich.
Wie viel Wasser brauche ich da?
Ich glaube, er ist wirklich happy über die Chance,
die Renner jetzt hat.
Bei der Amazon-Mitarbeiterin
hatte ich ein bisschen den Eindruck,
ja, das ist ein bisschen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen fake mit dabei,
aber dem kaufe ich das voll ab.
Christian, hast du kurz Zeit?
Christian hat sich gedacht,
oh nein, da ist er schon wieder.
Schon wieder.
Aber musste durch.
Okay, weiter.
Was denkst du da?
Erst mal kein Gebäude planen.
Christian, hast du kurz Zeit?
Was denkst du da?
Erst mal kein Gebäude planen.
Ich würde eher dahin gehen,
dass du noch einen Stahlbau planst.
Ich habe wie eine Bushaltestelle vorgestellt,
aber aus Edelstahl und dann Trapez.
Danke sehr.
Das kann man auch noch so schaffen.
Obviously Trapez, hätte ich auch so gemacht.
Danke.
Tschüss.
Feierabend.
18 Uhr, Mann.
Da bin ich schon zwei Stunden am MMO gegrindet.
Naja, nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz.
Sagen wir mal so 15.30 Uhr, 16 Uhr bin ich weg.
Dann gehe ich hier mal eine Stunde laufen.
Eineinhalb Stunden, je nachdem.
Und sagen wir mal so,
18 Uhr habe ich schon mich bewegt
und eine halbe Stunde MMO gegrindet
oder Video gemacht oder gestreamt oder so.
Aber 18 Uhr ist schon hart, ey.
Meine Augen sind echt müde.
Aber viel erreicht.
Der ist so happy.
Oh ja, um 18 Uhr noch.
Viele Leute wieder angesprochen.
Brutto verdiene ich monatlich 4.332 Euro.
Ich kriege dann noch eine Überstundenpauschale von 298 Euro.
Und das sind dann ein Nettogehalt von 2.908 Euro.
Es kommt nach einer Gewinnbeteiligung von etwa 5.000 Euro zusammen.
Also für Training geht das voll klar, oder?
Weihnachtsgeld ist ein ganzer 13er Monatslohn.
Also nochmal 4.332 Euro.
Ich habe es nur ausgerechnet.
Du kommst auf ungefähr 65.000 Euro Jahresgeld.
Also als Trainings...
Ja, man kann ja nicht wirklich Azubi sagen.
Aber als Traingehalt ist es doch okay.
Finde ich gut.
Brutto 65?
Das ist ja übel viel.
Ich habe noch keinen Plan,
was ich mit so viel Geld machen kann.
Bis hierhin sozusagen...
Wisst ihr?
Ich fühle mich...
Bei einer Sache mit ihm glaube ich recht verbunden.
Und zwar...
Ich meine, ich kenne ihn nicht.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck,
der hat einen sehr...
Also ich glaube, wir haben einen ähnlichen Lebensstil,
was die...
Was soll ich sagen?
Der Bedarf an teuren Sachen angeht.
Also ich gehe auch davon aus,
der wird genau gucken,
was er sich kauft.
Und...
Der kommt auch mit wenig aus.
Ja?
Also ich glaube,
da sind wir uns in dem Bereich...
Zumindest würde ich ihn so einschätzen.
Da sind wir uns da recht...
Ich glaube,
wir kommen beide mit wenig aus.
Und bei mir ist es ja nun wirklich auch nicht so,
als müsste ich irgendwie am Hungertuch nagen,
weil ich zu wenig Kohle verdiene.
Ich gebe aber nichts aus.
Ich kaufe mir alle paar Jahre mal einen neuen ordentlichen PC
oder sowas.
Ja, und letztens habe ich...
Ja, okay.
Ich habe mir jetzt nach 20 Jahren
auch mal wieder ein Auto gekauft.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich habe mir jetzt nach 20 Jahren
auch mal wieder ein Auto gekauft.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich habe mir jetzt nach 20 Jahren
auch mal wieder ein Auto gekauft.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich habe mir jetzt nach 20 Jahren
auch mal wieder ein Auto gekauft.
Aber ansonsten...
Das letztes Jahr war halt insgesamt relativ viel,
wo ich Geld ausgegeben habe.
Wo ich Geld ausgegeben habe.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich gebe eigentlich für kaum was Geld aus.
Ich glaube,
das ist bei ihm ähnlich.
Deswegen ist das für ihn
auch so unglaublich viel Geld,
dass er dann sagt,
ey, ich weiß gar nicht,
wohin damit.
Wenn du es gewohnt bist,
nicht alles,
was du hast,
direkt wieder rauszuschmeißen
und auf einmal doppelt so viel hast
wie davor,
dann weißt du nicht,
was du hast.
Was auch nicht schlecht ist.
Besser so,
als einfach sinnlos
das Ganze wieder
zum Fenster rausschmeißen.
Dann hast du eine Menge,
die du beispielsweise
in den ETF stecken kannst
oder sowas.
Welches Auto hast du dir geholt?
Ein Fiat 500e.
Bin ich mit sehr wenig Geld ausgekommen.
Und...
Musst keine Miete bezahlen,
das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Muss er nicht?
Jetzt überwältigt es mich auch,
überhaupt mal einen Lohn zu bekommen,
der mal die 1.000 Euro
bezahlt wird.
Und...
Das bricht natürlich weit
über die 1.000 Euro.
Aber...
Dafür habe ich eben
lange gelernt,
sozusagen,
habe lange studiert.
Das stimmt.
Das...
Übrigens,
ich muss das an der Stelle
jetzt einfach mal sagen,
weil ich in letzter Zeit
so Diskussionen mitbekommen habe,
dass...
Ich weiß nicht,
wo das war,
ich habe...
Ich habe letztens
irgendeinen Ausschnitt
aus irgendeiner Fernsehsendung
gesehen auf YouTube
und...
Also,
wurde in irgend einem Shorts
wurde das empfohlen.
Da hat jemand gesagt,
dass...
zitieren ich kann das nur sinngemäß wiedergeben dass er super privilegiert ist weil er studiert
hat oder sowas in der richtung so der hat irgendwie irgendwie gesagt er er spielt das
leben im easy mode weil er studiert hat und so was in der richtung und da habe ich mir immer
dabei war der aussage habe ich mir so gedacht so na ja aber du musst es dazu erst mal studieren
oder du musst es erst mal das lernen du musst es das durchziehen du musst es das schaffen du
musst auch was können also ist ja nicht so als könnte jetzt einfach sagen ach ja ich würde gerne
mein leben im easy mode spielen deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal studieren und dann easy mode also dazu
muss man sich auch schon ein bisschen reinhängen und je nach studiengang ist das sicherlich nicht
einfach er fordert sehr viel zeitinvestition sehr viel eigener persönlicher einstieg
einsatz durchhalte vermögen ja in gewissen wie kann man es nennen hartnäckigkeit auch da kann man
doch im endeffekt auch sagen hey nice da habe ich was auf die reihe gekriegt warum ist das leben im
easy mode verstehe ich nicht und der hat voll und ganz recht hier an der stelle der musste sich da
komplett durchbeißen der an hauptschulabschluss gemacht der hatte nicht irgendwie von ihren von
seinen eltern super krass gegen den schulabschluss gemacht und dann hat er sich auch ein bisschen
krass geld der musste sicherlich nebenbei auch noch ein bisschen gucken dass er über die runden
kommt ja dann hat er wahrscheinlich sein abi nach geholt oder wie auch immer das funktioniert dann
da hat er studiert dann hat er sein bachelor war sein master gemacht also dass das fällt
ihr nicht einfach in schoß da sagst du nicht einfach so ich mache jetzt mal easy mode beim
master also dass das gebäsche mein opa war da auch so mein opa konnte konnte studierte leute
nicht ab aber oben mein opa kam auch noch aus einer anderen zeit und mein opa konnte besonders
ärzte nicht ab da hatte er immer erzählt die halb götter in weiß sind wieder dauert also ärzte und
gerade studierte leute mochte mein opa ich eben es wissenín mein opa war ich habe übrigens mein
video wird man opa aufgenommen ist schon ein ganzes creativ der lebt mal opa nicht mehr der wahl ich bin
bei schicken highlighter und aging-gp-ziegOS ges melonnt Florida schon ganz lange aufgenommen ist schon eine ganze weile her noticing der war ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was die
war ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was die
überhaupt gelernt hat er war nicht elektriker er war wie nennt man denn so jemand der in einer
fabrik arbeitet und sich um maschinenelektronik und sowas kümmert nicht elektroniker vielleicht
vielleicht so eine vorstufe von mechatroniker ich weiß ich habe keine ahnung ich weiß es ich
weiß es gar nicht was mein opa genau gelernt hat zumindest er war hier war hier in der fabrik und
hat staum um rede gekümmert und heute wird man wahrscheinlich sagen hat die geräte programmiert
aber damals wurde nix feinmechaniker das könnte tatsächlich sein dass man opa feinmechaniker war
jetzt wenn ich das wort zu höre das könnte tatsächlich sein dass der feinmechaniker war
industriemechaniker industrie so ein mechaniker das könnte wirklich sein jetzt wo ich das wort
zu lesen
ist auch vollkommen egal hat mit der sache die ich erzählen will gar nichts zu tun ich meine
mein opa ja mein opa war als junger weiß gar nicht ob er schon volljährig war aber wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich war da irgendwie so 19 20 war im zweiten weltkrieg also mein opa ist auch ein paar
jahre jetzt gestorben also er hat richtig ganze kacke mitgekriegt ja der war dann auch
kriegsgefangener bei den beiden amis hat er immer erzählt die amis konnte er überhaupt
nicht
ab wobei im endeffekt im nachhinein betrachtet war es wahrscheinlich besser dass er bei den
amis gelandet ist anstatt bei den russen und danach hatte er dann hier in einer fabrik
arbeit ich glaube da war feinmechaniker das kann schon das kann schon sein zumindest der
war halt sehr sagen wir mal so arbeiter mäßig unterwegs und auch spd wähler so der ersten
stunde dann und hat auch immer was erzählt von die arbeiter tragen das alles und ach keine ahnung
er hat
den 2003
kurios ter zatorat
der es zu haben
du hattest
früher
das zuhören
wo
du
keine ahnung
wie
ist
peter
sich
noch
alle
ac
auf
je
ié
vier jahre
Der konnte Amis nicht leiden und studierte Leute nicht leiden. Wie das mit studierten Amis aussieht, weiß ich nicht. Da wahrscheinlich doppelt. Und der konnte nicht ab. Und gerade Ärzte konnte er nicht ab, weil der war so voll Arbeitermisch. Alles, was studiert ist, ist so privilegierter Elite-Shit, so nach dem Motto. Der hat teilweise schon ein bisschen in die Zeit heute wieder gepasst mit den Ansichten.
Ich sehe das ja ein bisschen anders. Da hatte ich auch regelmäßig Diskussionen mit meinem Opa. Seine Antwort war, wir hatten ja öfter solche Sachen, so nach dem Motto, ja, aber es ist doch auch so, dass du dazu auch was leisten musst.
Du musst das erstmal lernen, du musst das schaffen, du musst das verstehen, du musst das machen. Du bist dann teilweise mehrere Jahre am Start und lernst das. Hat er alles nicht gelten lassen.
Seine Antwort war immer, wenn meinem Opa nichts mehr eingefallen ist, dann wisst ihr, was der gesagt hat, das ultimative Argument von meinem Opa war, du hast recht und ich habe meine Ruhe.
Immer. Und ich sagte, ja, aber Opa, das ergibt doch keinen Sinn, guck mal so und so und so. Und wenn du dann gemerkt hast, dass ihm nichts mehr eingefallen ist, hat er dann gesagt, du hast recht und ich habe meine Ruhe.
Und er hatte auch keinen Bock mehr. Er sagte, ich will da nichts mehr hören von, du hast recht und ich habe meine Ruhe. Ja, ja, ja, du hast recht, du hast recht.
Und umgedreht, umgedreht, umgedreht lief das anders. Umgedreht lief das anders. Wenn ich, wenn ich dann gesagt habe, irgendwann mal zu irgendwas so nach dem Oda, muss ich sagen, Opa, weißt du was?
Klingt eigentlich gar nicht so blöd, ne? Klingt eigentlich logisch, ja? Und wenn ich dann gesagt habe, du hast recht und dann hat er dann, hat er dann immer gesagt, danach, danach hat er dann immer gesagt, der Opa hat für gewöhnlich recht.
Ja.
natürlich gefallen, wenn ich ihm gesagt habe,
dass er recht hat. Der Opa hat für gewöhnlich
recht, hat er dann gesagt.
Wie war nochmal der Spruch
mit der Kordel? Ja,
er hat
gesagt, später
wirst du nochmal schwer Kordel nachgeben müssen.
Der Spruch in dem Kontext macht
übrigens auch Sinn, ja, aus der Sicht
von meinem Opa, so als richtiger
Arbeits,
wie hat man das, nicht Arbeitsrechtler,
so Pro-Arbeiter-Typ
ist natürlich klar, was der Chef
sagt, ist Gesetz und
irgendwie, da muss man später
noch schwer Kordel nachgeben.
Wie bin ich jetzt da überhaupt drauf
gekommen? Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwie,
irgendwie hat mich das...
...überhaupt mal
einen Lohn zu bekommen, der mal
die 1000 Euro bricht und der bricht natürlich weit
über die 1000. Bin ich da drauf gekommen.
Dafür hab ich eben lang gelernt, sozusagen.
Ach ja, genau.
Dass dem halt auch nicht alles in Schoß
in Schoß gefallen ist.
Und ich finde, da kann man
durchaus stolz drauf sein, wenn man das hingekriegt hat.
Man muss
sich wirklich für eigene Erfolge
nicht schämen. Hab ich den Eindruck,
dass das, weiß ich nicht,
so ein bisschen im Trend liegt aktuell.
Wenn man was auf die Reihe gekriegt hat, darf man
da ruhig auch stolz drauf sein. Gerade
wenn es was ist, wo man sich lange durchgebissen hat,
sechs, sieben Jahre teilweise
am Ball bleiben musste, auch nicht
jeder schafft.
Ich kann mir da stolz drauf sein.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt die
Bude, die mir jetzt
gegeben wurde.
Als Training zieht man ja häufiger um.
Ach, der bekommt von der Firma
die Wohnung gestellt.
Das ist nice.
Auf der anderen Seite
musst du dann halt da hinziehen,
im Endeffekt. Aber, sagen wir mal so,
wenn man damit fein ist,
ist das nice.
Wenn man jemanden suchen muss, der ein, zwei, vier Monate
erlässt, gibt die Firma uns eine Wohnung.
Bezahlen sie auch die Wohnung.
Bleibt eben mehr hinten übrig. Ich hab mal das BAföG
zurückgezahlt. Sechstausend Euro muss ich da zurückbezahlen.
Das ist eine Menge Geld, wenn man noch nie Geld verdient hat.
Hat schon wehgetan, als der Brief ankam,
aber jetzt, wo es weg ist,
fühlt sich schon nice an.
Ja.
Ja, ab jetzt geht's
nur noch nach oben. Also das sind
Alokasien. Nachdem ich aufstehe, sitze ich auch dann
eben immer hier sozusagen.
Alter, der verstrüht so eine ultra
positive Energie, Mann. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie ich das aushalten soll.
Ich schau mir die Blätter an, ich schau mir die anderen
Teile an und
da gucke ich, da
mache ich dann irgendwelche komischen Experimente,
um zu gucken, okay, wachsen die auch im Glas drin
und sowas. In meiner Freizeit gehe ich gerne
ins Fitnessstudio, da ist das schon mit
aller Zufriedenheit. Ja, es sieht auch ziemlich gut
ordentlich gepumpt
aus, ja.
Mir gefällt das hier, viel Gewicht zu
bewegen, diese Power sozusagen zu haben.
Ich hätte ja, wenn ich um 18 Uhr fertig bin
mit der Arbeit, überhaupt keine
Energie mehr, ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen.
Ich mache meine
eineinhalb Stunde
Runde hier im Freien
und dann ist aber auch gut.
Nochmal extra irgendwo hin, dann
da trainieren und dann
wieder zurück.
Der ist ja vor halb neun nicht daheim.
Und dann muss er noch was essen.
Der macht sich dann was zu essen, dann fällt er
22 Uhr ins Bett und morgen geht's weiter.
Max, gehst du jeden Tag nach der
Arbeit laufen oder wie machst du das?
Also, ich mache das folgendermaßen.
Ich gehe jeden zweiten bis dritten
Tag, je nachdem wie die Woche sich das
anbietet, auch mit Gemiete und sonst was
und Abstände und so.
Ich gehe jeden zweiten bis dritten
Tag vormittags rennen.
Das mache ich meistens gleich morgen früh.
Ich stehe auf,
gehe an den Rechner, logge mich ein,
gucke ein bisschen rum und dann ist
meistens noch nichts los. Da gucke ich mal ins Monitor
rein, ob alles gut ist. Dann schreibe ich
in den Chat, ich bin nochmal kurz weg.
Und gehe schnell so
zwischen, sagen wir mal so um die 40,
30 bis
Minuten
rennen.
Da ist noch nichts los auf der Arbeit.
Und das ist auch nicht so wild,
weil ich kriege eh
Mittagspause abgezogen und ich futter meistens
vorm Rechner. Selten sitze ich auch mal unten.
Ja, und
dann mache ich den restlichen
Tag Home. Also, das ist an den Tagen, wo ich
daheim bin.
Wenn ich nach Frankfurt bin, sieht es natürlich anders aus.
Aber glücklicherweise
kann ich die meiste Zeit Homeoffice
machen. Ich habe das Handy von der
Arbeit dabei, wenn ich eine Runde rennen gehe.
Also, wenn irgendwie wichtig ist, kann ich mich anrufen.
Trägst du das als Pause ein?
Manchmal. Ich träge das immer dann als Pause
ein, wenn es länger dauert.
Letztens musste ich zum Beispiel
einen Umweg zurücklaufen, weil
ein freilaufender Hund am Main
das hat dann, glaube ich, 45 Minuten
oder 50 Minuten oder so. Genau, das habe ich eingetragen.
Aber ansonsten geht sich das,
meistens relativ gut, mit automatischen
Sachen, die man abgezogen kommt, aus.
Und man darf auch nicht vergessen,
ich mache auch öfters abends was, ohne es
aufzuschreiben.
Also, ich habe mich auch schon öfters abends eingeloggt, weil
ich im Teams gesehen habe, dass irgendein Entwickler was
geschrieben hat. Und wir haben noch mal kurz eine
Viertelstunde geguckt und sowas.
Ehrlich gesagt,
und das sage ich jetzt nicht,
um zum Gutwetter zu machen, falls
mein Chef zuguckt, weil er kennt den Stream nicht.
Ich glaube sogar, unterm Strich
mache ich
durch das Ganze draufgegucke.
Ich habe ja sogar das Handy auf dem Klo und gucke da
teilweise die Mails durch. Ich gucke abends noch mal rein.
Gucke mal kurz noch. Okay, ah, da haben noch
Leute in Teams geschrieben, irgendwie 21 Uhr,
wenn ich das Handy noch mal in der Hand habe.
Das alles zusammen, ja,
oder noch mal schnell einloggen, weil ich gesehen habe,
irgendein Entwickler hat mich angeschrieben. Das alles zusammen
ist
eher positive
Bilanz für die Firma
als für mich, von den
Stunden her.
Ich schreibe das nur auf, wenn das wirklich
bedeutend länger dauert, als die normale Runde.
Und das mache ich
vormittags, so jeden zweiten bis dritten
Tag. Ich time das immer so,
dass ich sonntags die lange Runde,
morgens, morgen früh die lange Runde rennen kann.
Da brauche ich mindestens einen Tag Pause vorher,
dass das funktioniert.
Und dann, wenn ich fertig bin, so
15.30 Uhr, 16 Uhr, dann gehe ich meistens noch
eineinhalb Stunden ganz normal raus
und laufe hier eine Runde oder fahre ein bisschen
hier ins, ich nenne es mal
Gebirge, wobei sich da, wie gesagt,
die Schweizer und Österreicher darüber kaputt lachen.
Ich habe euch ja mal eine meiner Lieblingsrunden
gezeigt hier, so durch die Berge.
Das laufe ich dann meistens noch, aber ich
renne da nicht. Also morgens wird da wirklich
gerannt. Ich laufe da einfach ganz normal
eineinhalb Stunden, ein bisschen noch
durch die frische Luft, so ein bisschen über die
paar Hügel drüber und
dann wieder zurück. Und dann
sitze ich wieder vorm PC und
mache Stream, Video oder
cry in the MMOs bis
23, 22, 22.30
oder so.
Und in den
Tagen, wo ich nicht laufe,
setze ich mich auf meinen
Fahrrad-Smart-Trainer hier daheim.
Weil ich habe leider aktuell kein Fahrrad,
es ist sehr zu kalt zum Fahren.
Nein. Ich gehe morgen.
Morgens. Morgens.
Achso.
Abends. Ja, abends ist tatsächlich
nur ganz normales Laufen.
Ich jogge nichts
abends. Nur morgens.
Abends ist ganz normal recht
zügiges, aber entspanntes Laufen.
Nicht joggen. Hast du Bereitschaft?
Ja. Aber
heute nicht.
Hast du Stehtisch? Habe ich, aber Laufbahn
habe ich nicht. Stehtisch habe ich.
So. Und
an den Tagen, wo ich nicht renne,
mache ich
meistens, wobei, wo gemerkt, ich
lasse auch manchmal Tage wirklich, wirklich frei,
setze ich mich hier auf meinen Smart
Fahrrad-Trainer.
Und wenn ich ganz heftig drauf bin, mache ich
manchmal sogar vormittags Rennen,
dann die Spaziergehrunde
und dann abends nochmal 45 Minuten Fahrrad.
Aber das mache ich selten. Das ist nur, wenn ich gar
so viel Energie irgendwie übrig habe.
Und auch gerade kein Kreisel-Cry in Stream
oder sonst was anderes ansteht.
Ich time das meistens so,
dass ich Rennen, Fahrrad
fahre, renne oder Rennen, Fahrrad
fahre, Pause oder Rennen, Pause
fahre. Irgendwie so, dass das
passt. Also ich renne mehr, als dass ich Fahrrad
fahre. Aber eins habe ich
gemerkt, seitdem ich regelmäßig auf meinem
Smart-Trainer hier Fahrrad fahre,
ich merke es deutlich später beim Treppelaufen
in den Oberschenkeln.
Also ich bin
jetzt ja schon öfters mal bei uns auf der Arbeit
in 8. Stock
Ne, das ist Blödsinn.
In 28. Stock gelaufen, aber nicht von unten.
Sondern vom 25. Stock.
So rum. Das ist Blödsinn.
In 28. Stock, vom 25. Stock
gelaufen.
Und
wenn du das zackig läufst, merkst du es.
Habe ich es am Anfang immer noch gemerkt, gut
in den Oberschenkeln. Aber seitdem ich
regelmäßig Fahrrad fahre,
muss ich sagen, ich merke eigentlich nur, dass
es mir warm wird. Ich merke
nicht mehr dieses Brennen in den Oberschenkeln
wegen Belastung.
Also ein bisschen was bringt
es anscheinend doch, regelmäßig Fahrrad fahren.
Fährst du auf Swift? Ja, mache ich.
Ich habe ein
Swift-Abo tatsächlich.
Ich heiße dort, falls ihr mal jemanden
seht, Omega-Keckel.
Kein Witz, das ist mein Swift-Name.
Den musst du
Vor- und Nachname eingeben. Ich heiße
Omega-Keckel.
Mir ist nichts anderes eingefallen.
Falls ihr mal
einen Omega-Keckel seht,
bei euch auf Swift, da bin ich das.
Welchen Home-Trainer hast du?
Ich habe ein Wahoo
Kicker-Core.
Da macht man
das hintere Rad
aus dem
Das hintere Rad
kommt raus vom Fahrrad und dann
wird quasi die Kette auf
diesen Trainer hier
draufgelegt. Die Kassette ist
nicht dabei. Da habe ich
mir noch eine
passende Kassette gekauft.
Mit den Zahnrädern.
Also wenn ihr den Omega-Keckel
seht. Wie war das?
Schon brennen die Beine nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Durch
Fahrradfahren brennen die Beine
nicht mehr beim Treppenlaufen.
Das wollte ich sagen. Ich bin jetzt öfters auf der Arbeit
schon vom 25. Stock in den 28.
hochgelaufen. Und am Anfang habe ich es immer
gemerkt in den Beinen. Aber seitdem ich regelmäßig
Fahrrad fahre, mittlerweile brennt das nicht mehr
beim Hochlaufen die Treppe in den Beinen.
Sondern mir wird es einfach nur warm.
Das Joggen hat
erstaunlich wenig
Auswirkungen auf meine Fahrrad-Performance.
Muss ich sagen. Gut, ich weiß es
nicht. Ich habe deutlich länger angefangen
zu Joggen als zu Fahrradfahren.
Aber ich habe den
Eindruck, dass es sind
echt zwei unabhängige
Sportarten. Also
sicherlich hat man die eine Ausdauer
vom einen bis hin beim anderen. Aber
die
die Regionen, die beim Fahrradfahren
beansprucht sind,
sind schon andere.
Beim Fahrradfahren merke ich es richtig
krass in den Oberschenkeln.
Beim Joggen ist es eigentlich eher
kreislaufmäßig, wo ich
nicht mehr kann.
Also ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft, dass ich kreislaufmäßig beim
Fahrradfahren nicht mehr konnte. Es waren eher die Beine,
die mir zu sehr weh getan haben.
Wobei ich es einmal, einmal habe ich es echt
übertrieben. Da habe ich mal
versucht, so zu machen,
wie es die ganzen Pros
machen. Und zwar möglichst
schnell fahren. Also nein, möglichst
viele Umdrehungen, also viele
RPMs zu haben und
halt nicht so, nicht so
wie nennt man, wie nennt man das denn?
Also nicht so einen hohen Gang.
Also nicht so einen schweren Gang
zu fahren und
leichter und dafür irgendwie 100
RPM zu treten. Kadenz.
Genau, Kadenz.
Kannst ja quasi eher so Drehmoment
mäßig mit kleinem Gang
oder halt schnell, schnell pannen.
Und ich habe mal so ein Swift, so eine,
die haben so eine, so eine, weiß nicht, ob das
Weekly ist. Ich glaube, das ist Weekly.
Weil da habe ich jetzt schon ein paar gemacht von
Weekly, so Weekly Climb
Challenge. Da suchen die sich immer
das Profil von irgendeinem halbwegs
bekannten Berganstieg raus
und bilden das in Swift ab. Dann kannst du hochfahren.
Da bin ich
einmal einen hochgefahren. Ich glaube, irgendwie 9,5
Kilometer oder so. War schon,
hat sich echt eine ganze Weile gezogen.
War jetzt nicht so super steil. Und da
habe ich das mal probiert. Leute,
ich bin da oben angekommen und dann habe ich
dachte ich mir, ich bin im Arsch.
Aber komplett im Arsch.
Und dann habe ich den Fehler gemacht. Ich bin volle Pulle
gefahren bis über die Ziellinie
und dann habe ich den Fehler gemacht.
Ich konnte nicht mehr, weil mir die Beine
wehgetan haben. Und dann bin ich vom Fahrrad runtergesprungen.
Also nicht runtergesprungen, sondern halt direkt
von den Pedalen runter, sodass ich das Fahrrad zwischen
den Beinen hatte.
Und mir schwindelig geworden.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum die sich
immer ausfahren
danach. Ich habe noch nie
so krass meinen Herzschlag gespürt,
und
benommen gewesen von
Sport machen. Ich bin
hochgestrampelt,
über die Ziellinie und vom Fahrrad
runtergesprungen. Ich stand da und ich musste mich echt
festhalten
weiter am Lenker, obwohl ich gestanden habe,
weil es mir komisch geworden ist.
Also deswegen verstehe ich,
dass die alle nicht vom Fahrrad springen,
sondern immer noch
1, 2, 3 Minuten
langsam weiterfahren, bis die
wieder ein bisschen runtergekommen sind.
Macht schon Sinn, ja.
Wusste ich bis dahin auch nicht.
Ich habe gedacht,
meine Brust explodiert, da hast du richtig
krass den Herzschlag gespürt.
Naja, zumindest so sieht es aktuell aus.
Ich wollte bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal
gucken, ich glaube,
wir gucken das mal schnell fertig,
weil das ist eigentlich jetzt ja durch, außer dass
er ein bisschen pumpt.
Man verdient hier viel Geld,
man kriegt aber auch sehr viel Verantwortung.
Übrigens, bei dem siehst du, dass der
schlau ist.
Ich vergleiche das mal
mit den Mädels aus meinem Arbeitsamtkurs.
Den ihr erklärt,
das Lebensziel war,
bei einigen, ich habe ja mal ein Video
drüber gemacht, von so vielen
Kerlen wie möglich Kinder zu bekommen,
damit sie quasi
leben können vom Kinderbekommen.
Und der
ist komplett das Gegenteil
von den Leuten aus dem Arbeitsamtkurs.
Der ist schlau,
der ist motiviert,
der weiß, was er macht,
ich habe da mal ein Video
drüber gemacht, ja.
Das hier.
Ich habe da mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
Ich musste mal einen Kurs beim Arbeitsamt machen
und da hatte ich echt
komplette,
wie nennt man das so,
das war für mich
komplett andere Welt.
Die Leute, die ich da
getroffen habe. Und da gab es
ein paar Mädels,
also man muss dazu sagen,
alle dort, ich war da nicht alt,
ich war da, weiß ich nicht, 20 oder so,
ich war wirklich nicht alt.
Und die ganzen Mädels dort, bis auf eine,
die hatten schon alle Kinder
oder waren gerade
schwanger.
Und ich habe von einigen dort
den Plan gehört,
das erzähle ich im Video auch
ein bisschen ausführlicher, ja.
Von einigen dort habe ich den Plan gehört,
ihr...
Also ihre Lebensplanung
ist, von möglichst vielen Kerlen
Kinder zu bekommen, dass sie dann davon leben können.
Die eine hat mir sogar
erzählt, dass sie neben ihrem Hauptmann
noch einen zweiten Stecher hat.
Das war, Zitat, das hat die so gesagt
zu mir. Ich weiß beim besten Willen
nicht, warum die mir das so erzählt hat.
Vielleicht sollte ich der dritte Stecher werden,
ich weiß es nicht.
Aber die hat sich,
die hat sich gedacht, auf geht's.
Hast du nicht
angeboten? Nein, hab ich nicht.
Aber ich war nett zu der, vielleicht hat sie
das reininterpretiert.
Ich hab der geholfen,
einen Brief zu formulieren ans
Arbeitsamt. Leute,
ich hab das nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass es tatsächlich Leute gibt,
die,
ich will jetzt nicht sagen, nicht lesen
und schreiben können,
aber so
schlecht und unverständlich lesen und schreiben
können, dass du es nicht verstehst.
Die hat sich
die ganze Zeit aufgeregt darüber,
dass die ihr vom Amt immer nicht antworten,
was sie fragt
und dass sie sie nicht verstehen und so.
Und
da hab ich zu ihr gesagt,
zeig doch mal, was du denen geschrieben hast.
Und Leute, ohne Scheiß,
du konntest das nicht verstehen,
das war kein Deutsch.
Also es war Deutsch, aber es waren
keine Wörter aneinandergereiht,
die einen Sinn ergeben haben.
Das war ganz weird.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht mehr wiedergeben.
Es hat absolut keinen Sinn ergeben, was sie da geschrieben hat.
Die hat dann erklärt, was sie wollte,
aber das, was da geschrieben ist,
hat wirklich null, gar keinen Sinn.
War sie Deutsche?
Ja.
Ich glaub schon.
Wir hatten viele,
weiß ich, ob man nicht Deutsche sagen darf,
aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, also
Leute mit Migrationshintergrund
waren bestimmt
60, 70 Prozent,
wo zumindest auf jeden Fall die Eltern
Migrationshintergrund hatten,
aber das war, glaub ich, eine Deutsche.
Ja, zumindest äußerst deutsch aus.
Zumindest die konnte kein Wort
richtig da schreiben und
zusammenhängende Sätze, die man verstanden hat,
auch nicht.
Und da hab ich halt mir den Brief durchgelesen
und hab gesagt, hier, ich weiß, warum die dir nichts
antworten, gescheit, die verstehen das nicht.
Die verstehen das nicht.
Da hab ich's halt gefragt, ob ich
irgendwie mal drei, vier Sätze schreiben
wollen. Die sagt mir was, was sie will und dann
schreibe ich das halt so auf, dass man's versteht.
Und vielleicht hat sie das schon so gedeutet,
wie ich will der dritte Stecher werden, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest die Erklärung,
warum das so schlecht ist, hat mich ja noch mehr
schockiert.
Was meint ihr, was sie gesagt hat darauf?
So, wenn's
ja noch umging, warum das so schlecht
geschrieben ist.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das wär ja noch
eine schlüssige Erklärung gewesen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Die Erklärung
war, richtig,
die Erklärung war,
sie muss nicht schreiben, ihr Freund kann das.
Das war die Erklärung
da drauf, ja.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt hat sie gesagt,
sie selbst kann gar nicht schreiben,
oder noch schlechter schreiben.
Und deswegen hat ihr Freund das geschrieben.
Also der erste Stecher in dem Fall.
Oder der zweite, ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher, aber ich glaub der erste.
Und der war auch komplett unfähig.
Leute, ich hatte echt
ganz große Schwierigkeiten in diesem Kurs.
Weil ich es nicht für möglich gehalten hab,
dass solche Leute wirklich existieren in dieser Masse.
Naja.
Der ist halt das komplette Gegenteil davon.
Der Mensch wird da auch nie
einen Arbeitsamtkurs machen müssen.
Der ist easy in ein paar Jahren,
der ist easy in ein paar Jahren,
super krasser Business-Strong-Manager
bei Südzucker,
oder bei irgendeinem anderen Land.
Wisst ihr, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen,
das ist so ein typischer,
das ist so ein typischer Startup-Typ irgendwie.
So von 24-7,
ultra motiviert,
super gut drauf,
hat immer Energie,
das ist so ein typischer Startup-Mensch.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Und auch vom Alter her.
Wie viel kommt denn jetzt am Ende raus?
Vielen Dank, das war's.
Wie viel Überschuss?
Ja, siehste, der kommt,
wie ich gesagt hab,
ich glaube, lebensstilmäßig sind wir da tatsächlich relativ ähnlich,
der kommt einfach mit wenig aus.
Zwei, ja, ja,
das ist das, was er wirklich überwiesen,
also das, was er wirklich übrig hat, ausgeben kann.
Ohne Miete, ja, natürlich.
Aber, ist doch egal,
es ging mir nur um den Anteil von,
was der ausgibt.
Guck mal, 75 Euro Freizeit-Lifestyle,
das ist nix.
Da gebe ich mehr aus.
Und ich gebe schon nicht viel aus.
Wobei, gebe ich wirklich,
was gebe ich für Freizeit und Lifestyle aus?
Ähm, sinnloses Elektronik-Zeug bei AliExpress manchmal kaufen,
ist ja nicht Lifestyle.
Ist das Lifestyle?
Ähm, das Rose-Fahrrad, richtig, richtig, ja, das ist richtig.
Ich habe einmalig Geld ausgegeben für ein Fahrrad, korrekt.
Und jetzt ist es kaputt, nice.
Ich wollte doch gerade mal gucken, wenn wir gerade dabei sind,
ob es mal wieder ein Fahrrad in meiner Größe gibt.
Danach muss ich übrigens gucken,
ob ich da übrigens was essen kann.
International ist auch okay.
Äh, weg.
Moment mal, so viel angezeigt.
What the fuck?
Ich glaube, das da.
Zwift ist Lifestyle, stimmt,
da bezahle ich 14 Euro oder so im Monat für.
Oder sieben?
Nee.
Ich bring's gerade durcheinander.
Entweder kostet YouTube in Deutschland 14 Euro
und Zwift sieben oder umgedreht.
Oder beides 14?
Dann beides 14.
Nämlicherweise habe ich eine YouTube in Deutschland gekauft.
Wo ist das denn jetzt?
Alter, könnt ihr mal bitte die Modelle zeigen?
Genau.
Double Speed.
Hä?
Ah, hier.
Also das ist das, was ich aktuell habe, was aber kaputt ist.
Und eigentlich würde ich gerne genau das gleiche wieder kaufen,
allerdings am liebsten mit 1x12 elektronisch,
was es noch nicht gibt.
Sold out in blau.
Sold out, nice.
Also, kann man vergessen.
Obwohl es sogar ein bisschen reduziert ist aktuell.
Ich habe das hier noch bezahlt für,
ich glaube, 3300 habe ich bezahlt.
Gibt's nicht.
Tja, sadge.
Aber nicer Dude hier.
Der wird's Business Enterprise-mäßig noch weit bringen.
Der macht Karriere-Crinder,
hat Karriere-Crinder-Qualitäten.
Kann ich nicht,
weil der Rose Shop bei mir in Globetrotter zugemacht hat.
Es gibt zwei Rose Stores, gab es bei mir.
Frankfurter, Globetrotter, ich glaube, in Wiesbaden.
Beide haben zugemacht.
Wie viele Tabs?
Moment, Moment.
Ich kann in meiner VM noch ein paar aufmachen.
Und hier, hier und in Kron.
Also schon ordentlich viele Tabs brauchen wir da.
Irgendwie, ich sage es doch immer wieder,
irgendwie muss man wenigstens, Leute.
Pock, endlich.
Haben wir die Hälfte des RAMs wenigstens voll.
Sind sie immer noch 24 GB frei,
aber wir haben es noch nicht.
24 GB frei,
aber immerhin ist die Hälfte des RAMs voll.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ja, genau so ist es.
Da passt noch mehr rein.
RAM-Disk, ja.
Genau, dann kriege ich es auch voll.
Okay, Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Relativ langer Stream heute
und wenig Videos, viel geschwätzt.
Aber letztens hat doch jemand geschrieben,
Max, Laber-Streams sind mir am liebsten.
Also denn.
Es gibt übrigens gleich ein neues Video.
Wenn ich gegessen habe.
Warte.
Umut, auch mal wieder am Start.
Nice.
Lange nicht gehört.
Noch eine Frage.
Pass auf, jetzt kommt was total wirres.
Ich kenne ihn,
der hat schon öfters wirre Sachen gefragt.
Pass auf, jetzt kommt was total wirres gleich.
Wo ist der Chain-Law eigentlich?
Der Chain-Law ist der King auf wirre Sachen im Chat.
Was hältst du von Wi-Fi-Man von Uni...
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Wi-Fi-Man ist das nicht von...
Nee, Moment, Mikrotik heißt, das heißt anders.
Ähm...
Die haben nämlich auch so eine Wi-Fi-Management-Software,
die, die crap ist.
Weiß ich nicht, habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Der Dongle, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin von Uni-Fi-Zeug ja, weißt ja, komplett weg.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich schalte das Video, ich schalte das Video 14 Uhr dann frei.
Okay?
Wir gucken 14 Uhr, okay?
Chat-Girl.
Ich achte drauf, wer guckt.
Wir machen es jetzt so.
Ich gehe jetzt auf und schalte das Video frei.
Okay?
Und dann müsst ihr zum Erkennen unter dem Video...
Was machen wir denn?
Keck Wait, okay?
Ihr müsst unter dem Video...
Also alle, die jetzt vom Stream gleich kommen und sich das Video angucken,
müssen Keck Wait schreiben.
In den Kommentaren unter dem Video.
Dann weiß ich, dass ihr vom Stream kommt.
Und die ist Destiny.
Nein, fließt nicht.
Ihr könnt auch Keck Leave schreiben.
Okay?
So.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
In ein paar Minuten ist das Video da.
Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Cu.
Keck Eat.
Keck Eat könnt ihr auch schreiben.
Ist auch okay.
Gibt es morgen einen Stream?
Weiß noch nicht.
Ich muss mal wieder ein bisschen Kreiselkreis streamen.
Was?
Ja, aber gucken kannst du es immer noch.
Okay.
Bis dann, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Ciao.